three
[Music]
two
hello hello everybody it is april 11th
we are live it is h3 tv let's go people
[Applause]
hey hey family family family family
family family family family family
family
but
[Music]
dan is fights this morning
family family family stop
[Music]
pretty good we are aligned energetically
this morning absolutely
so uh guys if you want to call in 808
hot meme
phone lines are open
um
they call them dumps
so we have breaking news guys breaking
news
james charles
put out a new video
um
called trying the cheapest makeup from
amazon
and boy boy boy
what do we have here james bye again
diapers
depends
do we have a close-up somebody found
the product because it's here it's like
grayed out i'm curious to see
if you can find it because it was like
small size like twink size
yeah was it really yeah it's small size
and you can't just let it slide please
so james charles he showed his amazon
and the man is buying diapers
now i'm not one to talk because i admit
that i bought diapers for my diet oh
come on you guys why you gotta do that
to me
what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
why are you doing that to me i don't
even remember why i
it's come up
recently on the show too
why was i wearing those i don't remember
why
oh we were doing a sketch
i think yeah i would imagine so
on the on the old channel
[Music]
looking good actually yeah it looks
skinny then
all tucked in
i sent the close-up
yeah so if you could um
if you could open the diapers please
we need a we need a close-up of the
product here okay so we have
depends so small medium small to medium
60 60 count maximum absorbency
for men and women
that's great
now we were we were having a debate here
we're like okay well that's funny but
why is james actually buying diapers
and so
obviously it could be
i mean there's obviously like medical
issues which isn't funny
like i don't know what kind of medical
issue would require you to wear a diaper
or
if i was
really want to give him the benefit of
the doubt i suggested maybe he has a
infirmed grandparent that he uh helps
take care of or something i don't think
that's true because it's a small medium
that could be grandparents tend to be
pretty big here in america
just in general right yeah
in general i mean in america you're not
fit and grandpa into small depends it's
just not happening i'm probably not
i mean do any of you guys have
grandparents that would fit into a small
depends
uh that's like a 28 waist dude that's
tiny when i worked at a doctor's office
we had
uh diapers and most all old people and
there was like barely any small mediums
like even if you are like
healthy
small waist like you want to be
comfortable small medium that's that's
very small actually if you can you look
at the size chart like what kind of
waist size is that for
uh depends
size chart yeah let's let's reverse
engineer this
uh a small
is a 24 to 30 inch waist a medium is a
21 all the way up to 37 inch waist
medium that's what it says depends small
medium but that's such a huge i mean i
would be a medium so i mean those
depends that he was ordering
24 to 30 my god
small medium i would assume would be
probably like you know 26 to 32.
it's for him
[Music]
definitely be in that extra large
category those are generous waste ranges
though oh absolutely
45 to 64 inch holy god they're very
stretchable
and adjustable so your boy is so let's
just say
it's definitely for
him and then the question is
he has some anal leaking
now we were saying well if he's getting
blasted in the ass hard enough
potentially you may need to wear a
diaper and a lot of you will say like
okay we've had a debate like
i don't think vaginas increase in size
from sex but [ __ ] actually do if you
have a lot of anal sex you can actually
blast open your anus you can definitely
get it a little stretched and we we
actually fact checked that my friends we
did some research did you yeah somebody
sent an article that said frequent anal
sex can result in a blasted open [ __ ]
right yeah yeah okay to sum it up and
yeah anal sex
so we were thinking well maybe he's just
got railed real hard the night before
or maybe it's for one maybe it's for his
uh boy his uh boyfriend who just you
know
there was another possibility his
boyfriend who just uh you know
finished his bar mitzvah or something
age-wise god
and then i think the we unlocked the
real reason right which is that we
deducted that james actually got a butt
job right what does a bbl mean
brazilian butt lift oh
bless you
aren't those actually like surprisingly
dangerous
well people actually die from that
procedure any any uh cosmetic surgery
inherently has risk um i i don't know if
that one in particular i've heard that
yeah because if they injecting fat into
your ass they can hit your veins and
then you just die
one of the major risks of bbls is a fat
embolism yeah
according to this article which is is
that deadly uh i'm an embolism general
is a pretty serious thing so i i imagine
it can be yeah it doesn't sound good
yeah
um
but he's fine
other than the anal leaking
now what's the recovery process for a
bbl because it seems like
a diaper might be included in that yeah
apparently uh
you could there can be some bleeding and
uh
i mean it makes sense right you're
having surgery on the thing that you're
sitting on all the time you know i could
see
maybe he's all leakage he could be into
kind of a child play
as a kink uh-huh
diaper play could be
speculate on that
no that's wrong can you pull it off can
you pull up some photos of his recent
because he's been posting pictures of
and it's like what the hell did you do
bro
uh well there's that one that you posted
recently
the giant nips right yeah or he
retweeted it or something right
right with the giant nips but that photo
is real where his ass looks like
monsters yeah
yes
so i don't know um what do you guys
think maybe we should do a poll
what's i'd be open to doing a whole
parameter and sorry that was me
yeah so let's maybe do a poll
okay
so the options are basically going to be
what's going on with
guys i'm not kink shaming i'm just
saying maybe he's in the diaper play can
we split also like some kinks we can
shame i feel like
like i get it if you're into whatever
but like
if you're wearing a diaper i i think you
you we can make fun of you for that
okay guys
sorry well especially when it's a dude
who you know has been caught repeatedly
messaging trying to groom children
children yeah it's probably okay i think
everything's on the table game yeah
basically
which is why we
should hide which is why we love this
required you know
uh what am i
he's a power bottom
no
that would
that's an option power bottom
so wouldn't that mean that the diapers
aren't for him though no if he's on the
bottom he's getting railed
so that would he that'd be up he'd be a
power bottom okay
right
i guess i'll take your word for it so
power bottom bbl bbl
um
it could be diaper play
diaper play
or it could be
or age play i guess they someone someone
corrected me age play
i don't like that yeah diaper play
someone said thank you heidi said
definitely acceptable make fun of diaper
kings thank you
some kinks we need to be made fun of
they go no keep shaming what about just
the right height no bucket required the
man [ __ ] horses
can we make fun of him you need an
asterisk next to no king shaming we need
exceptions guys
all right so power bottom bbl diaper
play
j-r-a or
infirmed
infirmed graham that's [ __ ] he's not
mad he's not let's just let's put it in
there to be fair he's not taking care of
anyone grandparent or maybe medical a
medical necessity medical need yeah
i can only do four so i'm gonna
those can be grandma slush medical yeah
exactly confirm grandparent slash
medical need okay here we go asking the
question all right so we have a pretty
good we know where the answer is
i think it's power bottom
i think it's the butt lift
but because there's so much evidence
that he's done it like it just yeah i
mean oh wow overwhelming bbl here but is
you can read in the recovery
is it saying you're going to be wearing
a diaper because that's stuff you can
read about yeah it says you can and it
may take up to six weeks depending it's
different for every person basically but
yes you can definitely be wearing a
diaper
yep
so we have 12 power bottom
and 65 percent bbl
only four percent given the benefit of
the doubt of a moment
the man's not taking care of anyone
for christ's sake
[Laughter]
so there you go there you go you got to
the bottom of it that's good though at
first i was genuinely confused by that
but the bbl definitely explains it wait
someone's saying i don't know what a
power bottom is isn't it someone who
likes to be on the bottom
i i i don't know someone to [ __ ] can you
find power bottom maybe let's see power
bottom
a person particularly a homosexual man
who dominantly or energetically plays
the receptive role
right i nailed it it sounds like you
nailed it yeah he's a he's an
enthusiastic receiver who's trying to
check you on your power bottom knowledge
oh my god
power bottom is the guy who likes to
wildly ride the peg of another dude
where did that come from maybe urban
dictionary i mean i to be honest for
this specific question i think they may
have the best answer
it says i'll read a verbatim the power
bottom is a guy who likes to wildly ride
the peg of another dude while he jacks
you off until both have bone orgasms
[Laughter]
also the high fiber oatmeal in the cart
yeah i noticed that as well sam
sam um correctly pointed out that he's
been eating a lots of high fiber
oatmeal there yeah that confused me
though because doesn't it
against you yeah that would make it come
out easier right yeah
you need some he's to eat less of a
school firmer yeah less less oatmeal
if you're in a diaper i would assume
but these are the important things we
wake up on monday to discuss
you know
these these are the answers
we get down to the bottom of things here
yeah get down to the power bottom of
things here on the history podcast
i'm going to wrap up this poll it seems
like the brazilian buffalo power bottoms
have it was 63 percent i mean
it's 63
[Music]
[Applause]
but there you go guys
i love you guys so much but you all
really need some lgb
qt why what did i say
uh
shut up
what what did i say wrong shut up call
in if you have a problem with my
character you got it right i mean you
you literally got it right power bottom
one yeah
shut up
you don't know anything about her
sexuality anyways the [ __ ] do you know
that's true yeah how dare you assuming
that none of us are you know [ __ ] lgbtq
plus
how dare you assume that right
right check yourself
but call in if you have a problem i'd
love to discuss
808 hot meme
right
uh let's see
yeah oh this is good we've got some
fresh cav cav memes
brian cavanaugh is the uh
worst person alive
in fact he's such a terrible person he's
trying to assassinate the birthday girl
this clip
is so gold
here's kavanaugh at a do we know who she
is or any info about this
i
i don't i don't know who it is church is
some influencer he's trying to get a
trailer exactly
yo have you heard about triller
like it's like tick tock but way better
yeah we we wasted a billion dollars last
year
anyway here's kavkav kev
[Music]
nice one a little too much wine there
cab cab eh
look at his [ __ ] face
i mean dude
he looks crazed birthday
he's sitting right next door too like
isn't that reserved for someone who
actually knows her
and this was obviously an outcome right
so he's clearly trashed there's drinks
on the table the man is an alcoholic i
mean yeah you don't you don't get like
how many dui's has he had no
i think officially well it was
one of them at least one of them was
reduced to wet and reckless i know that
wet and wild and wet and wild drive
angry i mean generally speaking i guess
one dui you could write off as like an
accident if it's like real on the blind
two duis you're probably an alcoholic
yeah
yeah it starts to get and i wonder who
drove him oh you know what i know he
didn't drive home because he had a court
ordered he can't drive anymore and he
needs a driver
first here that's what i read as far as
we know yes allegedly allegedly
so here you go
this is the
dude he literally hit her in the face
bro you should be worried about her a fl
a live flame hit her in the face right
on the cheek and just why are you doing
that he's so ah god he's such a goober
dude the flame slapped her face that's a
goober
if she had a lot of hair product then
she could have gone up in flame
such a cuck move dude
jeez yeah don't hang out with kavkav i
don't think
i shouldn't have to tell you that
whoever you are
you know
ryan cavanaugh
yeah one idiot
maybe we should add that to the website
what do you guys think
add that little good idea
oh she has 3 000 followers so she's like
so
he's so weird man i don't know what he's
up to and i don't know what he's doing
but there you have it little cav kev
update for you guys important you know
very important stuff
oh oh do we have any updates from i saw
someone uh dazia said i saw jordan
peterson speak at bitcon 2022 he was so
awkward it was surreal to see him do we
have any um
so i have some stuff about the bitcoin
conference i uh looked into it i did
look up the jordan peterson thing
because i was looking for some gold to
be honest
it was just really boring there wasn't
really anything
the only thing that was like kind of
funny about it is he wasn't actually
that uh
um
he wasn't that pro bitcoin oh really
yeah which uh didn't
really go over too well with some
corners of the the bitcoin cult because
you know how they why was he there to
begin with he's got nothing to do with
that uh he learned about bitcoin a
couple weeks ago and now an expert what
did he say that was kind of like not
probe so
for one he said that getting off the
gold standard wasn't um
wasn't actually uh devastating which is
like
basically the basis for the whole maybe
not the whole but a lot of like the
bitcoin and cryptocurrency in general is
like this idea that when we got off the
gold standard and started using fiat
currency that's like when the world went
to [ __ ] um so that's a big no-no um
he that he apparently doesn't believe in
and he also uh at one point said you
know he does worry that
if
bitcoin becomes like the de facto
currency of the world then it will move
beyond the ability of um you know
politicians to be able to regulate
um which yeah is like the point i think
bitcoin is incredible but it is an
existential threat to all of society
uh and so yeah that one um kind of goes
counter to their whole narrative as well
so uh
yeah i mean the awkwardness comes more
from i don't think he really even
understands like what that whole
community is about and yet was asked to
speak there but
honestly it was it was like an hour-long
interview i got like 20 minutes in i was
like this is just incredibly boring and
bailed so
so yeah
bitcoin is is is an existential threat
if you own bitcoin you're a [ __ ]
idiot
you're part of a giant
scam
being perpetuated by
billionaires that's actually true that's
the thing i learned about bitcoin that's
blowing my mind everyone thinks that
there's this revolutionary monetary
system it's literally run by the same
people that own the financial system now
basically
it's just a bunch of rich people getting
richer now
yeah i know um what's his name that dude
that you hate from shark tank was there
at the conference
or no no not cuban uh who do i hate from
shark tank what's the the bald dude's
name mr wonderful i like mr wonderful oh
i thought you didn't like him i mean i
don't know he's part of the crypto scam
like every rich person in the space
right i don't know why i was under the
impression oh you know why because he
did that interview on bill maher
somewhere where he was like
saying like billionaires don't need to
be taxed more
he has some horrible takes yeah but he's
funny about right yeah
take their money
i love that soundbite so much
well anyway
i'm still crying over all the bitcoin
sponsorships we've lost though all the
crypto sponsorships we've lost as a
result of changing our stance yeah
[ __ ] oh well
like coinbase is tr is they offer us so
much money for sponsors bro
they're right
no
it only
they'll only have money for those
sponsorships for another year or so
anyways you think so
yeah you think it'll be all done in a
year i mean it's not obviously crypto
isn't going away in a year or two but
the current wave it
we talked about this on the super bowl
episode yeah that was all crypto it
reminds me so much of that late 90s era
of the dot-com [ __ ] it's just like it's
just a whole house of cards and like at
some point
yeah it's a gold rush and it's gonna i
think you're right it's gonna crumble
but coin base is so big i mean they're
publicly traded they've got a huge
market cap there was a lot of big
companies that that crashed in that
first big tech bubble too i don't know i
i i could be totally off base on that or
maybe maybe the big ones will survive
but you know the the
the overwhelming ecosystem of scams is
going to uh
catch up with the space eventually there
was another huge creator uh the bad
bunny or whatever it was there was this
huge krypto one scam that just came out
that like david delbruck was involved in
and the paul brothers were involved in
and all this [ __ ] was like a 70 million
dollar
wait this is separate from oh wait yeah
yeah it was the one david the nft one
that we talked about yeah was it nft it
was in it yeah yeah
but
i don't see it man
i don't see it and the only people will
come making out like bandits are people
influencers are getting paid flat fees
and all the people running it you've got
steak casino which now basically owns
drake's entire instagram feed
that [ __ ] is wild i mean of course they
can pay drake they have literally no
expenses they make a good they make
everything back they probably almost
don't pay anyone out bored bunny was the
name of it
i mean they rubbed that [ __ ] out of a
shack
yeah it's running out of it oh [ __ ] or
was that rubet i forgot no that was fake
yeah that was steak headquarters
it was a steak and uh it was a shack and
uh
croissant curacao yeah
so
if you don't give a [ __ ] how you make
your money then if you're an influencer
you know crypto's a great spot
knowledge
so here is uh oh you want to look at i
kind of want to look at drake's
instagram lately how he's just turned
into this steak
[ __ ] boy
yeah uh
what was it cam cowan it was like the
last
five out of six of his posts
steak ads i just don't get how like
drake is so rich
he might be close to being worth a
billion dollars at this point and i'm
sure they're paying him insane money
but just how do you not care about how
you're making your money
i mean look do you want to know how rich
he is this is his private airplane this
motherfucker's on air force one
pretending like he cares about money
he's winning on steak
[Laughter]
uh the caption is the boy asked for a
new coat thanks steak
oh it's just
unrelated [ __ ]
more steak stuff balance 2.8 million
and that's all their money
so i was wondering how much does he have
to pay drake
to be [ __ ] look at this look at this
steak post
it's just a straight ad bruh
2.8 million views
like holy god lee they got to be paying
him like 10 million per post or
something i think
genuinely yeah
it's wild because if adam ross was
getting 2 million a month and that month
he is nothing
nothing compared to drake do you
understand
and the perception of this too because
he's like a rapper or whatever
people just think it's cool as [ __ ] and
they don't see a lot of his you know
people here probably don't see anything
wrong with it
wait so how many were stake related this
one steak related
i think uh cam was referring to his
story post there's oh he had lots of
story posts okay
yeah i think he's getting 10 million per
post i swear i swear it
so god bless
all all going to
stake headquarters
all in untraceable crypto baby
here it is guys
entry
a traceable crypto
hundreds of millions of dollars a month
excuse me it was the shack next door to
that shack here's this one this is the
real one
wake the [ __ ] up
i think this is it's a little nicer it
has a blue one right i sense it's in the
description oh this is it okay no this
one's nice this one's fine it's a nice
shack this one's actually legit it's
more of a bungalow than a shack premier
management partners it's got a nice gate
definitely a flagpole no flags on it
oh interesting it was windy that day
yeah take down the flag they're like you
know what let's not represent our
country today
this is not a proud moment for us
so there you have it it's a nice shack
you know
yeah aiden ross just to give you
perspective he has 2.5 million instagram
followers he got paid 2 million a month
drake has 107 million
therefore oh what is that is that drake
at stake headquarters
yo he's visiting their headquarters
that's sick i wonder how the tour went
he loves the view
view from the top
stakeholder corners how's that song of
his ghost made it
from the bottom now we're here over here
made it to the bottom now the whole crew
here
i mean they offered me i mean got
hundreds of thousands easily
they both have uh highlights that show
stake in their bios
bam bro
oh so aidan's still doing steak after
all that [ __ ]
seems like it yeah of course yeah yeah
six days ago oh every day is he really
still doing it i mean
i see him live very often gambling
probably not every day but yeah he
doesn't give a [ __ ] and nobody does
nobody cares flights are when they go
two day ago yeah every day nobody cares
make six days
nobody cares who aiden yeah
doesn't he still live in l.a
yeah
definitely
yeah it's illegal it's [ __ ] illegal
like how is twitch just let that happen
it's so weird
first of all if i i'm i'm gonna make an
assumption but if you could look at
stakes analytics
if you could get a true snapshot of
who's using their website it's going to
be people in the united states
probably
a
fit a lot of them under the age of 21
even despite it being legal i bet you
there's kids i mean like look at love
for example he they hooked his ass at 15
or some [ __ ]
that's so [ __ ] up yeah love is 10
years younger than me but when we went
to las vegas he was the one teaching me
how to gamble
yeah
totally yeah goddamn rasco yeah he's a
gambling expert that man
i i even like read the blackjack book
when i was 15. oh my god
as good as possible
oh lord help me jesus
yeah
yeah so steak
i think one day that whole company is
gonna there's gonna be a huge expose on
that whole company
massive fbi
uh the thing is i don't intervention
when we were talking about this whenever
i was months back
i mean from their perspective i i think
that they're keeping it all legal like i
mean obviously
they're accepting us players they're
accepting
players where it's illegal to gamble
yeah but those players are using vpns
and [ __ ] to get like they they appear to
be playing i think they have
they have due diligence
they cannot accept the card i mean if
you're somebody might yeah if you're a
legitimate gambling organization
the responsibility is on you
to do the due diligence to make sure
people like when you go to vegas you see
how crazy they are when they check your
ids yeah to make sure that nobody over
the age of 21 is gambling
under but yeah yeah under they're
they're very very strict it's their
responsibility yeah
yeah i do wonder how you know the big
casino companies feel about all this
like it's got to be cutting into they're
jealous right we're probably trying to
figure out how to get into it right yeah
i guess that's probably true
yeah yeah
interesting stuff
just saying just saying
just saying
so let's see cav cav almost killed a
woman
yep
my favorite tick tocker
is back
in the smallest box imaginable
wow i know we're moving off of this but
just this super chat is interesting
apparently ms kev said cause he he i
guess
very early on did do a couple of like
the gambling things but then if i recall
he was like ah this feels wrong
and he said that he
the most he got offered was 30 k an hour
to do gambling streams
[Music]
they pay him per hour
that's [ __ ] maybe you came for 10
hours it's 300 grand
that's cr do you see how they're
incentivizing people though like that's
insane they're like even if you just go
for an hour just go as long as possible
it's crazy 30 grand an hour let's
[ __ ] go dude
yeah i'd sell my soul
[ __ ] it you would do it [ __ ] it and they
might pick you up on it go steak
i mean yeah that's the problem it's hard
to uh
it's hard to turn down
that much money it's life-changing
you know
so oh do we have stuff about the lebran
guys yeah we do
people are asking those guys are [ __ ]
lunatics man
uh we're actually already at 32 minutes
okay let me watch this first
[Music]
he's got crazy mouth work y'all you
can't say he's not talented
i'm not sure why they include the cnn
[ __ ] i didn't understand that aspect
either
reporting live from the scene
[Music]
dude he is a right on beat you got it
that's skill
the man is killed
[Laughter]
the poster volcano duck said try to tell
me this isn't comedy heaven i dare you
it is
i think it is
the longer it goes on the funnier i'm
finding i have to admit see thank you
oh there's another really
there's another really fast one i want
to watch yo the baby's wild and man i
don't know what's with this guy but he's
giving me bad vibes baby tried to kiss
his fan and she curved him out a mayo
this is bad vibes all the way
yo
the vibes are so bad in this video
[Applause]
it seems that he's
blasted he's on he's drunk he's juiced
up boy
is that like the worst vibes ever
it's not good they're not good vibes
like dude
what on earth bro
hell nah dude you need to you need a
reality check quick
everybody put your hands in the air
unless you got aids what was that line
he did yeah well unless you got about
that one then don't put your hands in
the air
jesus bad vibes to baby
don't like it
all right well
um let's do it let's say thank our
sponsors real fast and then we got
we got the lebran family stuff we can
get into
that could probably oh
xqc versus keem you know love that joe
biden versus bts
you know we you know who we stand on
this fight
bts forever dude
[ __ ] all haters of bts
how uh what is this black white what is
this
so this is a tv show that came out
around
six i haven't heard of it prior but i
was going around the internet over the
weekend because ice cube was being
called out for being a producer of it
right i saw this on twitter this show's
insane yo
this show's insane
it's crazy that [ __ ] this [ __ ] actually
existed
so they took a blo oh this is the whole
first episode the first minute gives you
all you need yeah the intros so
this and what year is this from 2006
yeah
so i feel like that's too late in the
game for this kind of shenanigans
definitely like this wasn't so they take
a black family and a white family
and then they have to
they they literally do blackface on the
whole white family and make them live as
black people and vice versa on the black
family yep
that's crazy bro this [ __ ] goal
my name is bruno and i became a black
person
wow
right out of the gate starting strong he
doesn't look like a black dude he looks
honestly still he looks like a white
dude with just like who works in the sun
a lot right
it's kind of true yeah like i'm sorry
bro
no one knew that i was actually black
deal this is straight out of like a dave
chappelle sketch yeah i'm sorry but what
the hell is this
is that guy passing his white i think so
it's better than that it's better than
the opposite it's better than the other
guy i mean he looks like he could be
like a a light-skinned i mean you
wouldn't even i don't think you would
even think twice about it you think yeah
he's actually i mean i have to see it in
motion though
but but i'm sorry i got to go back to my
homie here my name is bruno and i became
a black person
like i'm sorry but this is just wrong
this is just wrong as hell man
oh whoa somebody in the chat said they
literally won an emmy for makeup no way
did they really can you fact check that
that's true that's the funniest [ __ ]
ever
uh black white emmy
i'd love to see the prom oh my god
outstanding makeup for a series 2006
winner
no
jesus no do they show the makeup process
because i'd love to see that it's got to
be in this i think maybe there's a new
timestamp baby
well i watch this yeah oh it's got to be
in the episode they're very proud of it
yeah
oh my god
no one knew that i was actually black
when i had my white man i pull up the
picture of chappelle in white doing
white it's literally i it's like
identical
chappelle used to do this character
where he would dress up as a white dude
and he would cruise to the world
yeah look at that [ __ ] it seems [ __ ]
he would go buy like a newspaper and
they'd be like it's okay you don't have
to pay for it
you're white you don't have to pay for
things
wait i think you're confusing that with
the eddie murphy uh
no
oh [ __ ] eddie murphy did a very similar
thing on snl way back in line oh yeah
oh man that's one of the best sketches
ever
yeah this one yeah yeah there that
they're like no you don't have to pay
for that sir you're white
but maybe i mean chappelle's i i don't
remember
if that exact bit was one from one or
the other but they were similar you
think we can watch this without getting
claimed no it's snl nbc god [ __ ] i
just want to show that one scene so
funny so
someone is shout said hassan watched us
all on twitch
of course he did like all seasons of
course he did somebody's of this show
right not of snl
it's around the uh four minutes 50
seconds for the makeup but if you oh i
knew it if you want to keep it here
in the beginning it's still i'm gonna
watch the beginning and then i'm gonna i
want to see the makeup process
for six weeks two families my family the
black family got together in a house in
the valley in la and we decided to swap
braces
stop it
you decided to
we decided to do that yeah
they're like the nice thing about
pretending to be black is i can stop
being black any time
right
that's true
holy [ __ ]
would go into makeup and become the
opposite race
we became black
[Music]
what the hell the worst one they gave
her like a wig
what the [ __ ]
dude this is so [ __ ] up
i mean so this was like an acclaimed
show at the time man the 2000s were wild
i mean they're hard reality can we say
their hearts were in the right place
here
i
i mean the fact that ice cube was
supposedly behind this tells me that
like
this was some harebrained idea of his
that
he thought
would come across not offensive or
something i i don't know i don't know
what the history behind it is well if it
weren't an emmy i don't think anyone was
offended at the time
i have to imagine there were people
criticizing it even at the time even if
they were the minority
they became white
then we moved in together we're talking
living together you know it's not like
you know you're gonna see them for a
little party get together and they go
their way and we go away no at night we
all live under the same bro
i can't this shit's crazy as [ __ ]
i like how it goes black too
the whole experience over my eyes just
made me more aware of my race yo what
the hell made him to theo bond
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ]
it's like uncanny i don't know it's just
so wrong
i'm a pioneer in this because this is
something that's never been done
changing color to see what it would be
like it was completely transformative we
got jobs went shopping hey white man we
would go out together he's the honkey we
were undercover we had hidden cameras
sneaking around hello
hello i am a black man what kind of
black activities is going on here today
hello fellow
churchgoers there any black activities
today i can partake oh whoa
what
okay
somebody in the chat says that bruno the
the the white guy that's wearing the
black face says the hard r n word like
15 times in the show yeah well he's
right he's got to blend in
he got the n-word pass wait is that is
that
if that's in the show uncensored i don't
want it to sneak up on us wait
he got the n-word pass from ice cube
i mean he's the producer
the oh that's crazy bro this is crazy
apparently he does a wrap here people
are saying
people are saying n word warning i don't
know if we should keep watching i'm
sorry but i i got to see it
i'm sorry i can't click away
if he's dropping hard r's i got to see
that
we did it all
we're the worgles a
typical white american family from santa
monica
i just wanted to really
poke into the issue of race
this guy like
by the way he doesn't
this guy's like ambiguously white i feel
like already
he's got a weird thing going on with his
face
i feel like you could find a wider
looking dude
i mean if they really wanted to to go
all you know what i'm saying i suppose
but just saying it's not edited meaning
are you saying it's not censored yeah
okay you heard you caught him say the
n-word yeah oh i can't wait
i gotta see what was the context
uh i don't even know all right i don't
know
okay let's let's keep going and see if
any flames would emerge
my mindset in life i get from my father
as an immigrant came to this country
starting from scratch and demonstrated
that you get what you want by working
extremely hard
i never played this game before i don't
know how to play i was curious to see
how the world would react to me as a
black person many times i was shocked i
feel racist
we are with the sparks family
one of the mods just sent me
a compilation of all of the time give me
give me give me the n-word but it's
censored okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay here
you go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i don't want to watch like 40 minutes so
more compilations
okay
it'll it'll be interesting
let me turn up the
video quality there a little bit for you
it'll it'll be interesting and i'm sure
it'll happen where i'll be in in black
and i'll get i'll be in black
get some attitude yeah sorry but i love
the title of this black white bruno
n-word compilation
awesome from some
prick white guy
and i won't have all the history of
resentment right that a black man has
and i'll be able to [ __ ] with him oh
just you know mentally spar with them
and go you know hey
guys
why
he would call a white guy that he's
saying
yeah and he's explaining this to a black
guy wow this is really bad but he's like
i won't take it personally like you guys
i'll be able to you know i'll be able to
mentally spar with them
i used to work as a doorman at a disco
you know somebody came up intoxicated or
didn't have the right dress on you know
they said come on
wait that was him yeah
he's describing he's not even using it
in a believable way oh bruno please
also drop in the hard er i don't think
anyone's buying that i told them that
now just you know
yeah that's right
i don't think the goal is to pretend
you're black right it's just to like see
what it feels like when you have dark
skin
no i mean it seems like the premise of
the show is pretend that you're black
they're like exchanging lives you know
it's like that that uh wife swap show
that existed where like two moms from
different families would swap for a week
or whatever it's that but with uh really
racist slant
those focus groups were really
eye-opening i look forward to having
someone say hey nick
you know you're a son of a i hate you
[ __ ] you said
you know you guys are going gonna get a
lot more out of this
than i am because you know you're gonna
be black and i'm gonna be white right
okay well you said it was gonna happen
you know so far i'm kind of waiting for
somebody to go hey nick
god would you stop you really bruno
didn't want to go back he wanted to stay
black yeah he liked it he's
i wish they'd done you know more white
jokes frankly i thought
that that's that's what
eat that white stuff and y'all gonna be
happy you're
oh it's funny when they said
oh man he's feeling himself way too too
much in this oh this is our thumbnail
nice
our new thumbnail james charles wears
diapers
that's great
wow this show's incredible you guys
oh he's so racist like but not because
he's even saying that word you could
tell
he's just like yo i'll be able to deal
with it nobody's really being super
racist to me yet this sucks this sucks
dude black's boring
by the way if you guys are actually
interested so there there was a writer
there's a book called black like me i
read in college i don't know if you guys
have heard of that
um
this guy
back in like the 40s and 50s he
underwent a really dangerous procedure
to turn his skin black he like dyed his
skin like permanently black
he was a writer journalist and uh
he went to this like live in the south
with nothing and actually like immersed
himself in a genuine way
and uh
it's very it's a very good book it's
actually like a historical book really
highly recommended never heard of this
before yeah black like me it's a really
good book
uh he died actually of the of from the
inc he actually died from the procedure
yeah
yeah he was he but he like um
he actually became like super depressed
and [ __ ] up from the experience
because he actually went down there
during jim crow and [ __ ] he did not die
from the ink yes he did
i'm looking at it right now he died from
diabetes in the 80s
oh i thought he got
hang on the author there have been
persistent rumors that griffin died of
skin cancer which purportedly developed
from his large use of doses of whatever
this is to darken his skin
uh he did not have skin cancer but
experienced temporary and minor symptoms
from taking the drugs
especially fatigue and nausea so yeah i
guess that's like an urban legend that
he died from that that's why i learned
that in school it's crazy a teacher
would give you bad info
i mean in college you'd think they would
[ __ ]
fact-check a little bit but anyway it is
a very good book it's a short read too
relatively but black like me
uh unlike this show
um
let's see the makeup uh
the makeup here
you as an adult
should know that you just don't call a
woman a [ __ ] i didn't know that i
really didn't know what to expect but i
didn't know it was going to be that
intense she's going to be crying a lot
she keeps me though
where's the makeup here 10 years old 4
30
and i'm a white girl
here we go so exciting to be a part of
this project
i don't know what to expect
i'll pick up some other expectations and
characteristics and maybe end up walking
a little differently
my name is carmen
and i'm going to become black i'm
getting spray painted
i'm turning black gradually i'm brian
i'm 40. and i'm going to become a white
man
i'm still amazed at all those colors
making me white
i see browns and blues and greens and
red but the finished product i look like
a white guy i've knit and i'm 16 you
know all right is there any other good
compilations or not
not that i've seen apparently
is that the theme song
yeah i think think so it says that it's
going to premiere at the end of
that video and there's like different
scenes from the show in that music video
so
yeah i think it's just like wait i want
to see the dad rapping i heard he does
that the white dad uh let's see everyone
in the chat saying i gotta watch the rap
okay let's find the bruno rap
also apparently the girl does slam
poetry people are saying come on
let's see uh black white bruno rip
uh hassan reacts to bruno's that's the
first result
uh
let's see
i'm trying to see is he he can't be
rapping in the first episode already
kenny
if i needed to write a poem and memorize
it i really love words
i do and like to me you can never have
enough adjectives
i it sounds like she's working on
something rap related
my name is sheree busby and my favorite
entertainer is prince okay blessed i'm
an avid michael jackson fan my name is
jonathan my favorite performer is dave
chappelle um my name is rose and my
favorite entertainer yo this is so weird
you imagine people like are you
pretending to be black right now
like are you
are you wearing paint
how do you explain that
ma'am
ma'am why is there black paint coming
off you at the moment people in my
hometown used to be paranoid that they
were like fake arabs infiltrating the
mosques and stuff oh for real yeah like
the government i could see the
government doing that yeah the [ __ ]
they literally did yeah they actually
they definitely do they definitely do
that yeah they were always looking at me
i'm like nah i'm just
you're fbi for sure it's like dude if i
was under you think the government's
going to send a white guy undercover
they'd come in all dark and [ __ ] up
looking
or just like way over the top you know
what i mean they said in brunei
i love the cranberries so the
cranberries
this
this [ __ ] is wide
open get her out of here
red alert red alert crickets i love that
it's just crickets
cranberries
ian what do you think about this
[Music]
i was just curious if you had thoughts
about this social experiment
oh that was the wrong button man
but i'll press it anyway
[Music]
okay there's the ian's thoughts ladies
and gentlemen
what are you afraid of ian you only have
one opportunity to make a first
impression so my first impression was
like i love the cranberries what what at
least she's being honest you know
that
whenever we do our palms we have by the
way the cranberries it's bad for the
kids like getting [ __ ] involved in
this it's like this is so horrible well
you're lying to these people who are the
cranberries it's the i think they go
zombies zombies
[Applause]
[Laughter]
wait she tells them she's in blackface
at the end okay i gotta watch this okay
i don't know how to face this i'm
standing in the mirror faceless my
mama's at my shoulder telling me to
escape this there's so many far before
me with more life stories of prison and
death i'll take a deep ass breath what
what what is this that torments my
existence that removes the joy in every
single instance
i can't wait to see how
i can't wait
she's gonna be like i would grocery
shopping the apples were two for one
bought some apples son
their shit's all deep and crazy
who got
got the idea that i was ready for this
yeah good question like
a lamb
and a lion's den i'm always down for my
black people though sometimes they be
acting so evil yeah this is episode one
right out the gate episode one baby
straight to slam poetry
i feel bad for this girl that's horrible
to put somebody in
though at times i feel an alien blood by
the way you know you could go sit with
them if you're white you don't have to
pretend to be black to go sit with them
right
yeah that would be a much better way to
you know like i'm sure you'd be welcome
as a as yourself yeah
oh this is brutal
through these veins and this thought
sustains the aliens me
these people rock and they're speaking
about being black from their heart of
hearts and i'm hoping to god that this
sounds black
okay oh my god you did not thank you
many words my life the so simple
complexities of a human psyche to even
relish in my thoughts of romantic stride
my skin to his
holy [ __ ] that's why in your head
[Laughter]
[Applause]
my touch returned a mutual undulation of
want and reciprocal acceptability and
performance a ritual so profound the
taste of sex the body flush with hot and
sticky fantastic a basket of unbroken
fruit a dripping bouquet of red ripe
juices
the soul spread lavishly over the human
chemistry when discovery
look at his phrase
well she they were doing about like
identity and race and then she came out
with a poem about like sex yeah it's an
interesting choice and pleasure were
encouraged thank you
i mean
it could have been worse she could have
tried to speak from the heart about
being black that's true that would have
been way worse that's true at least you
know
yeah exactly yeah that's true
though
wow
wow
wow wow wow
were you nervous
shitless yes
i felt that you were nervous so yeah
just uh you have a lot of big words i
have a lot of big words i don't get you
know and you have to know your audience
and know that if you're speaking
to an audience of people that not
everybody's going to understand
what you're talking about
that was hard
this project is so much more unnerving
she's like oh so glad to be white again
the end of the day
so stressful
and
probing than you can possibly expect it
to be
so how was today for you i was about to
ask you
yo i need more of that i put that right
into my veins man
i gotta look for more of this
this era of reality television is is
never gonna be matched again dude inject
this right into my veins what is he
doing now life and a certain way no [ __ ]
not expecting
about my life you say it's a bad day
when i tell you that someone
doesn't acknowledge my existence or if i
speak they don't speak everybody have a
shitty day on that particular day that
nobody wants to speak or i don't get
good service or it takes them too long
to deal with me because i'm black i've
been black for them 41 years almost i
know when i'm being bullshitted because
i'm black or when somebody having a bad
day and that's the thing that you won't
grasp but you won't understand because
you want to debate every goddamn thing
that we sit up in here and say and we're
just trying
yeah uh the rap part please
it is a little bit more difficult this
is going to find you if you go in with
an open heart and love and
guys where's the wrap i need it but my
life is i get i don't know where it is i
i've been searching around for it can't
find it it's not fine i'll upload it you
guys got any intel on where this wrap is
located let me check this on this video
again
here here's the whole here's the season
one
so let's go to episode two we got it all
on youtube here
i'm brian i'm gonna become a white man
my name is bruno i'm going to become a
black person along with my family oh my
god bruno i am never around black people
this is one of the last
bastions of caucasian america i felt
proud i'm beautiful well there's some
neat chops maybe i'll come back down
again with rose there is many shelves
oh
you got a lead i think i got it all
right give it give that here mega
awesome nerd coming thank you
one of the most incredible places i
think i've ever been and heard anybody
speak
super racist i can't imagine wait i
think she's coming out as white
how it would feel for some it might feel
pretty like whatever and
some others could be deeper and i don't
want to start thinking that i know
because i'd like you to tell me
so please
give me what you've got
to me you seem uh
extremely intelligent well spoken and i
appreciate that you uh take this
opportunities not as entertainment but
that you truly appreciate it i think it
already happens some haven't heard since
the beginning tell you and i don't
exactly know how to say i think i'm
actually a white girl in black makeup
yes i live in santa monica i've told you
the truth since the beginning except for
the fact that i've walked in here in
makeup and that is the lie
this writing class is one of the most
incredible places i think i've ever been
and heard yeah these people are just
gonna go home and feel like [ __ ] like
that's just so [ __ ] up
nice job ice cube
somebody said uh they donated twenty
dollars and said when i was in sixth
grade they used this this uh show to
teach us about racism
showing sixth graders this like like
because the show exists or because of
what's in the show i have a feeling
right i have a feeling
it unfortunately wasn't not for the
reasons it probably should have been
shown
anybody speak
i can't imagine
how it would feel for some it might feel
pretty like whatever and
some others could be deeper and i don't
want to start thinking that i know
because i'd like you to tell me
so please
give me what you got
to me you seem uh
extremely intelligent well spoken and i
appreciate that you uh take this
opportunities not as entertainment but
that you truly appreciate what you can
get out of it and what anybody else who
sees this can get out of it so i do
appreciate that and that you are genuine
what are they going to say they're on tv
i say to you i have no animosity it will
i can only imagine how hard this might
be for you so i just want to let you
know that if you need to lean on me and
i hope to speak for everybody else and
just lean on us i think it is important
that you do befriend us and get to know
us in ways that you might have never
known this before that's nice very
gracious
all right let's get to dad rapping
uh yeah i sent the link here in the chat
yes
baby
let's go
i'm living for this
why you're afraid some hard ends
uh
if it happens it happens we'll find out
okay guys uh this
oh geez uh is something that i i made
actually um
months and months ago
it's called midlife rap months before
this project even came about i bought a
camera and a computer so that i can do
my own video projects and i ended up
doing a rap video after watching rap
videos
for a long time and getting kind of
frustrated i thought you know the
middle-aged guy or the middle-aged
person
should have an opportunity to speak
his or her mind as well and it's sort of
uh you know who you know who deserves a
voice middle-aged white people
i got sick of watching black people do
rap
the most silenced group
nope
they're just
they don't have a strong enough voice in
today's world
this guy's like robert downey jr's
character and tropic thunder
too deep in don't know who i am
commentary on the today's rap scene
nick you might in particular like this
i'm anxious to show to the sparks and
see how they feel about it so the fact
that he did this before the show is
pretty weird it's like you have a weird
agenda dude
it seems like the perfect opportunity
but ladies and gentlemen this is called
midlife rap
[Music]
a midlife rapper
and i rap them a to z
i'm middle aged and dapper with a
vocabulary
see that that's that's racist
he's like i'm tired of these black
rappers with no
this vocabulary is so brutally cringe
who is this guy like
is
does he have like a
i saw someone say he should be laughing
he might be an actor but i don't think
it means it's fake
i mean a lot of people are going reality
shows are actors just yeah if they want
to be on tv that's why i'm wondering if
if he's like stopped up anywhere else
because this is brutal
no i don't wear giant golden chains back
[Laughter]
dude what the [ __ ] bro
i don't disrespect the ladies i don't
call them hoes and slot [ __ ] [ __ ]
where's the super vocabulary you were
talking about
he's doing the head move like a black
guy
and he's really
slamming
rappers you know just really ragging on
them i tell tales that are squeaky clean
i stay out of polish station station
station
i mean it's just really obnoxious
horrible
it's actually it's just super racist
disgusting
it was just like ridiculous i work hard
to feed my children well eat some
lessons about life you've slapped your
so-called [ __ ] if not stabbed them
once or twice you just hear the words
not a little bit harsh and controversial
i don't blame anyone for my flight i
don't blame the man it done me wrong i
don't wave my hands all around i don't
bend my fingers up and down i don't
mumble incoherently i don't wear a big
old mastiff brown brown brown crown
what dude this is like straight
gnarly this is like clan membership
so now it's so much worse than i thought
it was yeah this is like holy this is a
top tier
it was at this moment that he knew
he [ __ ] up
i wonder if this guy learned anything at
the end of this or if it just reinforced
all of his racial stereotypes
[Applause]
[Music]
what the [ __ ] bro he is feeling himself
sure what do you think of that
[Music]
what do you mean
[ __ ] [ __ ] i kind of ragged on the
rapper
that offend you no i mean i think he he
did that thinking we were gonna get
angry and stir up something it didn't
even bother me i just thought like how
ridiculous you are we have to look at it
like just like when a comedian talks
about
i mean i just look at it like that i
don't know if it was meant to get under
my skin type things or not but it didn't
offend me at all i didn't even care
about it that's his creative expression
let him have it
actually i think both me and my mom were
really skeptical feels a little bit like
making a separation between two
different cultures that might not exist
what do you mean cultures like with a
midlife man in white america versus the
black rapper which seemed to be the name
by the way i never mentioned black
personally oh stop it bro
this guy's [ __ ] dick yeah this guy's
whole family's like please god i don't
want this back
so check it out um
here's bruno who's imdb he was indeed an
actor
um
curiously his career
kind of dries up
right around this time i mean he has a
few more recent credits but like short
this is probably like a student film or
something i wonder if we could get him
on i want to ask him if this was real oh
my god i bet we could i mean look the
cursed man he played uncle bob in 2020
after a seven year hiatus hard hitting
role dude
the first man my boy uncle bob
i can reach out yeah let's see if we can
get any of these people on the show
okay i'll reach out though
i mean
if i were him i would never want to talk
about this ever again
the only reason if he if
i were him is if it was like set up you
know if it was like scripted
oh i mean i'm sure
yeah i mean like if the show is like
make this rap and then we're going to
show it to them right then they did him
dirty
i guess it's possible
but i don't know the guy's he's he's a
great actor if if that's the case i
don't think that's what happened
i don't like that rap and i've told him
before it's really offensive to me i i
squirm
just because i think especially being in
the center of something that is so
racially conscious
but say you can't you know why because
we're taught
growing up
that these kind of things
you know we don't take it personally
who's we
blacks i'm
totally impressed with your creativity
and ingenuity
um
i was offended by the rap song
there's a tone to it
that's what it is
um
it's the same issue i've had with you
throughout the project i don't
experience bruno having compact that's
good at least his family's setting him
straight god damn bro
[ __ ]
that was gnarly i gotta say
way worse than i expected way worse
there was three seasons of it
yeah
the show came back up after
hashtag ice cube transit after people
learned that he was one of the executive
producers
[Laughter]
wow
it was a bad day not a good day well you
know i think the kids are are at least
coming off relatively well there like
with good intentions the dad is a piece
of [ __ ] that guy is just irredeemably
racist seriously
wow that was a rabbit hole
i saw some people in the chat say that
uh bruno and the wife got divorced after
this
did they really well good for her
because
this was like too much yeah i don't
think
they got divorced after the show people
are saying
wow mr bruno ruined his whole damn life
by
yeah the i i agree someone said the
daughter mother don't look that bad i
agree it seems like they have good
intentions
yeah there was only one season i don't
know where the three seasons came from
and there's only six episodes this is a
short experiment well in other news
britney spears is pregnant you guys oh
my goodness
with an interesting announcement
i lost so much weight to go on my maui
trip only to gain it back i thought geez
what happened to my stomach my husband
said no your food your food pregnant
silly so i got a pregnancy test and uh
well i am having a baby
four days later i got a little more food
pregnant it's growing if
if two are in there i might just lose it
obviously won't be going out as much due
to the paps
getting their money shot of me like they
unfortunately already have
it's hard because when i was pregnant i
had to
i had prenatal depression
i hate to say it's absolutely horrible
women didn't talk about it back then
some people consider it dangerous if a
woman complained like that with a baby
insider
yeah i understand that
last time britney showed any
vulnerability they lo they [ __ ]
locked her up for life
but now when we talk about it every day
thank jesus we don't have to keep that
pain as a reserved
proper secret this time i will be doing
yoga every day spreading lots of joy and
love shout out to britney spears who's
living her best life
after the conservatorship it has finally
been
done
and a special
[ __ ] you to uh her dad jamie spears holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] holy [ __ ] [ __ ] balls oh
girl
whoa girl
oh my god
oh we have a caller let's go let's go to
the lines
yeah let's check our callers here
um yeah cam said uh sarah has um
something very interesting to talk about
uh 74 is the number
i'm just reading the update here
oh my goodness this sounds really
interesting
okay sarah
thanks for calling hi
so i understand so much
yes i'm such a fan i love you guys so
much well i love you too of course
and i want to say you have it seems like
you have a very
unusual problem here
yeah this is unusual for me in general
like i've done like hundreds of calls
like this um and this is the first time
i've ever had
this situation come up so what do you do
for a living let's start there
so i work in sales
i sell patient simulators so basically
they're medical robots that
nursing school students and in hospitals
will practice on my products before they
work on people
so this is for
they use these for doing cpr and stuff
like that
cpr
birthing you name it oh wow they can
give birth
wow
specifically with covid we saw a rise in
sales for like um respiratory conditions
they wanted to practice with
my simulators as opposed to real
patients because they had a shortage of
respiratory therapists for like
incubating patients and stuff like that
yep
okay interesting so it seems like an
expensive product for realistic so
they're
they're not like um they just do cpr
like they'll blink they'll register you
in the room how much one of these dolls
cost
i'm sorry how many how much does one of
these dolls cost
it varies it can go anywhere from about
two thousand dollars to a hundred
thousand dollars wow wow
okay yeah
so
it's a very niche field um like i have
for example like i had to do a lot of my
demos um from my own home so i have like
genitalia all sorts of parts all
throughout my apartment because i had to
do it virtually
um
so i was like i'm not sure if you were
going to find it interesting or not but
this was the first time i've ever had
this situation come up and i don't know
how to deal with it it's for tomorrow
so i thought
maybe give me some insight
um
sure what's the problem probably
like
maybe
100 demos with the simulator
um it's a customer that i have
who
called me today and said we have a
situation
um we have a birthing simulator of yours
that was violated
um
do without what you will and i said well
what do you mean he said well it's a
criminal investigation they have like
caution tape around her
medical robot if you google like a
patient simulator
you can kind of get an understanding of
what i'm working with
can you look up a pregnant uh body see
how i want to see obviously i don't want
to show the anatomy but i mean i i just
want to give people an idea of what
we're dealing with here but so so one of
them not graphic as possible
because they could be graphic yes
i can imagine let's see
so
one of your patients bought one of these
for practicing birthing so it is that
the doll has a a
a functional
uh anatomy it has a realistic anatomy
yeah
yes so it's super important because
especially like in
areas where you have
high risk low frequency delivery they
need
you know if for example like a shoulder
dystocia where
that's a major complication
we need our you know our doctors to know
what to do how to respond
um so they do a lot of work with these
simulators especially like
where i live which i don't want to
disclose i'm trying to make it as
anonymous as possible because there's
very few vendors for this equipment
um
so
like i said i've done this many times i
have a lot of body parts like simulated
body parts i guess if you will
throughout my apartment but i've never
this is like the worst case scenario for
me
um
yesterday
um
i got a call
originally that there may have been an
issue with the simulator and then today
i officially got a call that it was
violated
um i guess
what someone they don't know and they
can't disclose
um
violated the simulator can we show that
i don't think so don't show that i don't
know
dan pulled up a photo sorry but dan
pulled up a photo of
a fake baby coming out of a fake you
know
uh
body yeah i think i may have found a
very similar one right here
yeah
so so somebody
so where was the body located
it was located in the hospital so it was
in a hospital was it a medical they do
like when i say they do practice like
they'll use us those run codes so
they'll take the simulators and they'll
train their staff on the news like
sometimes the standards will change for
what they require
um
you know every year sometimes it may
change so they'll run codes to make sure
that everyone's trained and knows what
to do if this situation were to happen
okay i want to ask you some questions
as much as we want
so
the the doll was violated how did they
find out that this violation took place
do you do you know
how someone talked to momo lee there's
this she's got cav cav dirt apparently
okay check out that
that's super mess sorry to interrupt how
did they know it was violated
um how i like i said i don't want to be
too graphic because i'm trying to be
they found
[Laughter]
yeah there was um there was a lot of
evidence that there was obviously
um
penetration i guess yeah so it was cream
pod
right and so
it was probably the probably one of the
people that worked at the hospital i'm
assuming it was behind a closed door
it had to be because um typically in
these
um labs they'll they'll lock their very
expensive equipment it's not something
like it's capital equipment yeah they
don't just
yeah probably talk to the janitor i
would assume
people like saying
there's no they don't know who it is
they have no idea from what i understand
i heard this call originally yesterday
no have they have they conducted a uh a
uh r word kit on the doll yet
so i don't even know
like i don't know pressing charges
i'm sorry is the doll pressing charges
i don't know
i mean she can't she's not ai this one
isn't she's you know this is a very
expensive i mean it's awful so
how much did the
i mean
what do they want you to do about it
sarah i mean genuine like it sounds like
that's kind of their problem
well i mean i like my the way i do my
business it's not like a a one-time sale
like i'm in sales but i support the
customer so i will go and evaluate it if
there's an issue
this is not something i've ever
had happen before it's my worst fear i
thought about it like you knew this was
common
you were waiting for this call you
knew
well i mean take it you're gonna have to
clean it out i don't know if you're
gonna someone's gonna have to sanitize
that thing right because how much did it
cost
this is like a
thirty thousand dollar simulator can i
can i suggest like a uh
maybe a chastity belt when it's not in
use by a medical professor professional
yeah i mean listen like i i have no idea
how to even approach this is also an
account that's
going to purchase more from me right
yeah so i have to go under like from a
business perspective i don't have any
idea how to approach this i brought it
up to my boss he said just
show up
do what you can do
um
but yeah no i i really
in the like
issues right it's a doctor it's a doctor
who's just trying to run training
someone obviously had this happen he's
embarrassed i'm embarrassed what's the
best way for me to spend
sponsored by team skeet this uh segment
is
i don't know wait did you say 30 grand
it cost
yes now that's a robusty
that's an expensive flashlight the
champagne that
i don't know what to tell you i mean you
guys are going to have to find a way to
clean it out and i'll be honest it was
inevitable so you all need to have a
procedure for cleaning yeah you really
should have seen this coming
even knew it was coming so yeah i mean
some sort of chastity belt like even
suggested
by the way this is uh fiddlesticks
what's the name of it fiddlestick
oh fiddlestick coffee the finest coffee
under there
fiddlehead it's fiddlehead kettlehead
fiddlehead you keep saying fiddlesticks
i was making them fiddlehead coffee the
best
you're gonna have to clean that robustio
i'm the youngest one in the company this
is the only person who's ever documented
this happening it happened
literally today i officially found out
i just
i don't even know how to go about this
like it's just
get a douche casing put some bleach in
it
get the work dammit
i would i just don't think i can because
it's a criminal case yeah
yeah in that case you shouldn't know
well then what do they want you to do
yeah like are they just they want you to
give a new one no just stop
just telling it you just tell them
whatever i can do just tell me what you
want me to clean it do you want me to do
you want the police that i mean they're
a hospital if anyone's qualified to
desanitize it it's them for christ's
sake
well right i think what they want is
because it was so expensive right and i
can understand this
um
it's not a hospital that gets a lot of
funding too just to make that like get
you they want a new robot
i think they want me to evaluate
the damage right see
if it's still usable here's what i
wanted here's what i want i want you to
go in there tomorrow
do your best do your professional best
and uh come back and report to us okay
let's donate ai absolutely
yeah we can donate yeah we have a room
we have the top part yeah that's true
yeah maybe with it
in while it's in the donate maybe take
some photos if you can i'd love to see
those i do i want you for you i don't
know how i mean these are not a real
person
uh uh yeah true there's no like it looks
violation privacy violation yeah i don't
think so i don't think so
yeah this is definitely do that yeah
take some photos come back and and
report to us okay sarah
okay all right all right
all right you get in there and you
thank you you clean that robusty up and
you make it nice and new oh my god needs
a vaginal reconstruction surgery or
something
make it nice and tight like it was
before
all right thank you guys love you all
right thank you sarah thank you for the
call love you too good luck tomorrow
there you go
that's a new that's a new wow yeah
that's a new one that's a new problem
new problem
talk to me baby
i mean i'm i'm surprised they don't
already have a procedure for this it's
gonna happen
you sell robusties
[Laughter]
well you know on on howard a few weeks
ago they had uh a
real doll company which i think would be
very similar similar material how they
talked about the cleaning process they
use like a micro mobile soap or whatever
the [ __ ] yeah talk to them yeah there
was there's a company i heard they rent
sex dolls that's it yeah you don't want
to pay you don't want to buy the whole
thing so what they do is
they'll leave a sex doll in your hotel
room
for a one night stand and then reuse the
[ __ ] and then they he talks
about how they wash it and the the
sanitation process they use and
talk to him
there's experts out there is all
is all we're saying
i actually saw a pair of these dolls on
the plane when i flew to america
and they scared the [ __ ] out of me dude
what i thought they were like
here i sent you the picture yeah i got
it here like what the [ __ ] is this
when i was waiting for my flight they
just rolled past me in like wheelchairs
and i thought they were like patients
like actual real people with plastic
masks
they got jackets on they look like kanye
i was terrified dude and then wait why
is he wearing it i forgot i don't know
dude i thought these people these were
like burn victims with plastic coverings
or something right right yeah and it
scared me so much like i could not stop
thinking about it and
he was yeah and
and like when i arrived to america there
was the first thing i told ab like i saw
something really disturbing yeah we're
like nice to meet each other you know
how are you and then he's like yeah dude
i saw some [ __ ] up stuff on my flight
well they bought them they bought them
seats and everything
yeah dude it's nice that that one has a
neck pillow he's nice and comfortable
this guy had to sit next to the thing
no he's a carrier he's one of the people
oh he's a chaperone yeah so apparently
what they do is they train these two
people to travel with uh people with
disabilities and yeah
but basically i sat down behind behind
them they somehow came in like they
obviously got to see down before me
and i saw them from my seat that was
maybe four rows back you can see the
other pictures
oh i was actually sitting right next to
them almost so you didn't understand
what was what was no the whole flight i
couldn't sleep i was just thinking about
these two people
and they're giant by the way they're
like over
six like four or something you're giant
it's so scary and i could not sleep i
couldn't stop thinking are you wondering
why they they were so motionless
yeah
i don't know we have to ask her but i
heard noises from them and that's what
tripped me up the most we're like making
muffled noises
and when i went up to the bathroom
uh in the in the middle of the fight i
talked to the guys and i was so relieved
when i heard it was dolls
what were you scared that it was
i don't know i just just unsettled i
don't know they were like horribly
disfigured or something and i just felt
bad for them basically
i felt really bad for them that's all
yeah
yeah you could well this guy's got a
nice juicy mouth open for you if
anyone wants that's why it has a thorn
that's why it has a chaperone sitting
next to it to protect anyone from just
having their way with them yep
what are the chances of that i've never
seen that before
so i'm actually kind of glad to hear
what they were because i wasn't sure
very very informational
yeah
i think we should change the title to
james charles wears a diaper and lebron
family everyone's super hyped about the
lebran family documentary
okay
you know
the la bryant
let me see if there's any other
interesting calls
while we're on the topic
jared leto's story
[Music]
getting through a quarter life crisis
about baldy
knife threats
[Music]
okay we have a call about the top bottom
stereotype
[Music]
okay so i've been accused of having
being uh
wrong with the power bottom
characterization matt
wants to uh correct me here
matt
maddy
alrighty i don't see that you've
accepted the call yet no it's it's there
i see it oh yeah i do see it
matt
matt matt matt matt matt matt
matt stop drop
oh i just dropped him
oh my god i dropped him right when he
said if you call me uptake
i can call him back yeah call him back
uh okay one second
let's see how does that work i'm calling
i'm calling you back matt if you're
watching i clicked the call back
yep sorry matt i just clicked the button
and then you've said oh [ __ ] oh hey oh
that was easy
we heard you talking like the split
second that he hadn't hit the drop the
call but okay we're back so matt what do
i got wrong experiment
so
first and foremost because i know how
south these polls can go very quickly i
want to establish my stance on james
charles and the diapers
okay i think he totally probably has the
fetish
oh you don't think it's bbl
i don't know enough about the topic
but if i had to put my money on it i
think he probably just has a photo is
that the feeling or is is there any
evidence
it's a gut feeling
and you so you think he gets off on
wearing a diaper
and do and soiling himself and all that
uh you know that's a little too far i
just
you know i i i don't know but my gut
feeling tells me it's probably some kink
it's probably nothing else okay well
that's an interesting perspective
certainly i just wanna i just want to
come in strong on like james charles
stan you know that just so we can move
on quickly good okay
okay
because i know you like a strong stance
early on
thank you
well okay so
now no it and so like
oh actually i have an update i'm sorry
matt
matt regarding your comment about james
charles upon further research we've
found that more websites say there's no
diaper needed after bbl so it could be
okay
that he likes what they call age play
and he isn't a young folks well we know
james charles has strong feelings about
age yeah exactly
wow sister snapped well i know one thing
he's got to be real embarrassed he
accidentally included that
brutal
okay matt i'm sorry i'm sorry for the
tangent there so what have i got wrong
about top bottom uh stereotypes there
yeah so like and this is kind of an
ongoing thing it just kind of um it made
me really want to call in today um
because like with you guys
just like when you guys were all
you poor straight males all you know you
a group of four straight males having to
discuss such a topic i mean you know
it's okay i mean you're not
it's it's it's okay i just wanted to get
involved because like i know there's a
lot of times that comes up where you
bring in um
where you often bring up people that you
feel inclined i know often you feel
inclined
to describe someone where you think they
might be a bottom
and i i think that that's often a
misconception
that like bottoms may be
passive or
the
well i just mean that he likes to
partner i i just mean that he likes to
take it up the butt
correct and but how can you know that
about someone well that was just a
theory about because he was he wears
diapers it's just a theory oh no i'm
moving on from james charles i'm sorry i
don't care about james charles not much
well like he should be in jail
i mean down that one yeah what do i care
about okay so
i'm trying to sometimes like i think i i
don't keep a running tally i love you i
don't i'm not keeping track of
everything you do wrong i'm not keemstar
i don't have a document okay on my desk
i appreciate that like there but there
have been times i think i think one that
comes to mind was maybe jordan peterson
that you described as probably being
someone that would be a bottom that's
the only one i can think of off the top
of my head but like i've i've heard you
at times maybe say like oh this is
something that might be a bottle
um and i think that sometimes like
that's not oftentimes like a
misconception like like i think if you
met like i'm gay let me
let's just throw out there i and um
and i mean i'm married and i think like
if you met me and my husband you
wouldn't necessarily be able to tell
which is which and that's something that
like you can't always tell and it's like
you might always think that the bottom
and the power bottom is a good example
of me looking up top but like you can't
always tell like who's the top who's the
do you find it offensive if i say by
being like oh he's he's probably a
bottom is that the problem to me
absolutely it's offensive um because
it is because
it's because it
saying someone's a bottom in particular
i think is probably a bit troublesome
because it kind of
i it starts to kind of
the gay men already you have to you have
to deal with certain assumptions about
femininity and masculinity
i mean and i mean i'm sure you
understand that i i i'm not going to
throw out the whole i mean it is funny
though i just i don't know i think the
problem is that the term power bottom is
very funny to me
and sometimes it's hilarious and
sometimes you know these these alpha men
give power bottom vibes
they could be but it's not a bad thing
right it's not a bad thing that's the
problem i think the i think maybe the
joke is the dichotomy of like their
their persona of ultra masculinity but
then like the joke being that
their power bottom but yeah okay i i see
your point it's not anything wrong i see
your point as a good counter example
like i i found i didn't find anything
wrong with your in brittany's
usage when you guys were kind of
throwing those things around like when
you went brain you were talking about it
the other day i didn't find anything
wrong with anything you said that day
i i mean i'm alright everything there
was okay
matt i will be more conscious of my use
of power bottom
uh oh i don't yeah but i think it's more
i i think it's more okay i just i think
the description of
like throwing out that someone is just a
bottom like
because it it
it it just ascribing certain
roles to people i
yeah if that's all i'm asking for is
just be a little more conscious of it i
know you don't i know you don't mean any
harm you never mean any harm i'm
harmless
you you you know your humor gets away
from you you're well let me ask you this
matt is it possible
yeah
are you are are so would you consider
yourself a top or bottom or you don't do
that the labels i knew you were going to
ask me that
i knew you were going to go there
and i mean this was all peace and love
and with respect ethan it's not in your
business oh sure i mean you can that's a
totally valid
response you don't have to answer
the question because
because because from there
but you have a preference one way or the
other
yeah and but that's the other but that's
another dangerous assumption too can i
guess
don't have a preference can i guess
that's another dangerous stereotype
what's that can i guess what is your
preference
you can will you tell me if it's right
if i guess right no well but
either way
how about this how about this
you do a good job
you try to learn from this and do better
and then in five six months when you've
shown some growth then i'll tell you
okay matt
seems fair
matt
the reason you're okay you know what i'm
not gonna get into it matt but i but we
all know which one you like you prefer
yeah i think you probably do yeah and
that's great
people that receive you but you
understand as long as you understand
where i'm coming from
to be honest i don't really i'm trying
but i i don't i don't i mean i get it
like i get the i get the thing that like
power bottom it's this weird assumption
to make or to use it in a derogatory way
i get because
okay to be on the bottom is to give it's
to give you know it's a gracious thing
to give and to receive like that
i think you're misunderstanding what a
power bottom is like because generally a
bottom is like the receptive partner
right
they're someone who's just receptive a
power about so generally a bottom is
kind of assumed to be the more passive
partner a power bottom is someone is a
bottom who is just the more active
bottle oh okay i see so they'll they're
they'll ride in they can write a power
bottom will ride it where a regular
bottom will just kind of lay there
i generally yeah what did you think a
power bottle was i thought it was just
someone that liked receiving rather than
giving
yeah no that that's just that's just the
bottom
okay so so the power bottom is someone
who rides enthusiastically
and they're probably the more active one
okay so what's the problem i missed i
misunderstood the
the label
yeah of course but you could be i guess
you could be on some days at bottom and
some days of power bottom which is great
god bless them god bless you
yeah sure okay matt well keep it keep
keep it up man i'm sure you're
i'm sure you are having fantastic
sex and everything's good do you wear
you don't need diapers or anything right
i oh oh about anal leak it's the only
thing i know about anal leakage i think
that's i have never heard of that with
in anyone right i have never heard of
that i think that's more i do think that
happens sometimes in older gays but i
think it's more of like a thing that
kind of maybe is
um like i think it probably comes from
other things that come with being older
can i ask them can i ask you a question
i mean no disrespect at all oh boy
sure this is just purely in the pursuit
of
knowledge well first i first i i
appreciate you saying like
correcting the anal leakage thing but
like if you are a regular receiver of
anal sex and i'm not saying you are i
don't know
uh but but if you were does it does the
poop pass like any differently from
before is it all normal functions like i
get it it doesn't leak out but i wonder
if it just comes out a little
different
no yes no i mean i i have um i'm more
like i mean i
i i think you and i have more similar
stomachs but yeah i know it's i think
i'm more i relate to you a lot i'm in
the bathroom a lot yeah but no it's it's
regular okay
my stomach's about as zero as yours but
yeah i know it's more normal okay well
there you go you see that that's good
knowledge to have
so all right i've never heard of anyone
i i've never heard of anyone having like
just that bad
it does narrow the options doesn't it
on the james charles diaper thing yeah
all right matt you take care you enjoy i
am bts army i appreciate bts forever all
right
bts forever
[Applause]
i do think you have a favorite one
though if i remember correctly i think
jimin was the one that you wanted i mean
everybody's chill i think yeah so i
think when you when they do ask who your
favorite is i'm pretty sure it was jimin
that you wanted to [ __ ] so i wouldn't
i wouldn't disgrace him by saying that
yeah
that's okay i just want to let you know
okay well thank you though thank you
matt thanks for calling i appreciate you
you take care right
all right you take care of you got it
all right thank you bye
so i'm not quite clear like i get i get
the
there's a distinction in power and power
bottom which i get now yeah but i didn't
understand necessarily the
okay you know what let's just take it
for what it is on top and who's on
bottom
you're saying a power bottom could be on
top
that seems more like no more no it's
just you're making the power about the
dynamic yeah off of
the
position yeah yeah and which you know if
you're on the bottom doesn't mean you're
like a beta you could be alpha and also
still be on the bottom
right especially if you're a power right
but
but assuming in general he's saying is
what's and the problem is
yes
it's not about the what the dynamics
like theoretically jordan peterson if he
was a power bottom he could still be
alpha
right
yeah i guess
yeah
because he rides it with gusting he's
right in a vengeful way so yes i think
that'd be alpha yeah i think we all
learned a lot here today don't you guys
think
you know
delete me from this conversation
guys i'm just trying to learn okay
thank you people are saying on bruno of
the gay community
come on guys what did i do wrong i'm
just trying to learn
that's so funny we don't talk about
bruno i think we need an alpha bottom i
think we need more distinctions we need
alpha bottom and beta bottoms
more distinctions
so who is gay
no more
no more alpha beta anything doesn't that
make you does that does it make you gay
and i got news for you that means you're
gay
guys just chill i'm just joking around
come on like you said i'm an ally you
know i [ __ ] ride or die
for all human rights first and foremost
100
all right let's get back on track shall
we
we shall
so let's talk about the labrance
i gotta pee first though sorry guys oh
my god
you freaking kidding me right now
the la bryant family
these people are so we talked about the
lebrons before
yeah because of the the fake cancer the
cancer click bait yes i'll be right back
i'll be really fast okay take it away
dan how bad do you have to pee right now
sigma bottom says someone
what would it what would the sigma
bottom be sigma bottom it's like
you're upside down
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm saying i
don't know
you know why why don't they teach this
in school
i feel like it's important i believe
that there's actually a giant debate
raging in uh certain states of this
country oh actually that problem
actually so
uh it will be a while before we
have
bottom 101 as a course you can take like
i feel like
it's more informative than like [ __ ]
geometry or some [ __ ] you know
it depends sometimes there's geometry
depending on how advanced you're trying
to get 69. specialty
[Music]
nice one
somebody said jordan peterson is a
crying top yeah i feel that
you think jordan peterson cries when he
has sex
of course beautiful
i think he probably does this orgasm was
the most beautiful climax i've ever had
[Music]
oh hold on i'm coming
really mean
i keep hearing that sound bite
everywhere
was a gentle man is not a good man or
something like that or a gentle man is
not a good man
listen here [ __ ] listen here buckle
michaela
why are you always gonna bring her
for all my south side canadians that
know me best i feel like me and michaela
might still have sex i fed that [ __ ]
angus
[Music]
she got the meat diet thing holy [ __ ]
[Music]
oh god all right what else is going on
in the chat here
up in my ass you know
all
weekend sound bite zac started singing
it you know the parody of the nirvana
song
something's in my ass it's been stuck in
my head all weekend my wife asked me
where what is that from i said zach like
everything from that it's from
i want to give a shout out to the crown
bears by the way shout out shout out
cram
out rest in peace to um
what's your name
it is the cranberry yeah dolores died
recently she overdosed uh tragically
overdosed the overdose yeah are you
spreading it
man no i believe she did overdose now
singer death cause of death i think
overdosing is a good way to die in terms
of like ways to die well you go out on a
high yeah you go up feeling good you
died by drowning oh well that's that's
not a funny that's like the worst one
she overdosed on water how'd she
i think drown
by alcohol intoxication and drowning
caused by drowning
i i she drowned by drowning
was the name dolores what dan
uh
oh riordan
oh riordan
something like that all right let's talk
about the lebrons so yeah we first came
to uh our attention
some months ago
they were click-baiting
they thought their daughter
was had cancer and then they found out
she was fine
and they made this whole documentary
this was their thumbnail look at this
[ __ ]
she got diagnosed with cancer
documentary yeah she didn't
the kids are fine these people are
morally so this is they're they're super
conservative christian that's still
schtick
and they're also incidentally like the
most morally bankrupt freaks you can
imagine i mean just by default they have
a family channel so okay they're freaks
um
and then clickbaiting your own child
dying of cancer is like
honestly
like way below what even the ace family
would do i don't even think the prince
family has has stooped that low
uh
they've gotten close
because they have click baited their
kids like having horrible like skin
rashes and stuff and like all kinds of
they've gotten close
videos of their kids in the thumbnail
right yeah
they've definitely gotten close the
thing about the lebran families though
is they're like serious like disciples
of god in their channels like sirius so
at least you know with the prince family
my child was abducted and
violated
my child was was abducted by a serial
child predator
yeah so this is this is um
this is where we know them from
but they just released a 36 minute
documentary
on youtube titled abortion
documentary
it's an investigation by the lebrandt
family on discovering the truth about
abortion
as you know
abortion is a
almost no debate about it so it's good
that the lebrant family of all people
are qualified to make a full
investigation
the truth about abortion also to help
women gain better access to health care
medical resources here's the documentary
and then i guess
obviously there
think abortion is murder
but the part that really stuck out to
people
is um
where is it is it in the beginning where
they compare it to the holocaust and all
that [ __ ]
oh here it is
comments are disabled
apparently has a lot of dislikes
although you can't see it
here's a clip deaf noodles posted
i've been filming this documentary we've
been asked by our friends my family by
mentors why are we making this so
there's so much at risk why are we even
making this people with mentors are just
bad vibes
i don't know why but
you're uh holy [ __ ] i have the plugin
where you can still see the dislikes
okay
so there you go the dislike button is
still out there going strong click that
for me would you thank you
oh comments turned off
do you know what i'm saying people that
talk about mentors are weird in general
no i don't know what you're saying at
all with that really yeah what does that
mean like tai lopez my mentor
everything's like they're their whole
thing
mentor who has mentor who has a mentor i
always describe you as my mentor yeah
but i'm not your mentor people have
mentors
who the [ __ ] dudes any of you guys have
a mentor like just illuminate me please
no people that inspire me no but that's
not a mentor we all no i have master
class baby that's right i don't need a
mentor that's right
all right love said
hopefully someone out there knows what
i'm talking about i know what you're
saying and i refer this to the seinfeld
episode do you know do you remember
which i'm talking about go ahead where
jerry is dating a girl with a mentor
and
the mentor ends up dating kenneth
um
the other comedian dude
kenny uh
oh yeah
kenya yes um
so i i can see what you're saying
nobody has mentors unless you're like i
don't know you guys know what i'm
talking about like to refer to someone
as your mentor is just odd
my mentor
well it can also mean whatever the the
craft is too like do you mean it in like
a life sense like a life it seems like a
life coach the way these people use it i
had a mentor he screwed me over i'm not
even joking wait who
[Music]
uh
when i started college there was this uh
this dude who kind of like was head of
the student organization yeah and uh i
don't know he taught me a lot helped out
a lot of people in my class that were
coming in yeah
and i just found the guy's a snake i
don't know
there's a lot that goes into this yeah
mentors
watch out
people just yeah it gives multi
multi-level marketing vibes that's the
meant that's the problem with the mentor
and people that describe themselves as
mentors there you got a real issue
trust me
dan
i don't i still think you're totally
who's your mentor dan you have a mentor
i don't have a mentor but
who's your mentor
i wish oh man
that would have been awesome
no somebody that you either work closely
with who's older or more experienced and
imparts a lot of wisdom to you as you uh
grow up i mean i feel like a mentor is
like a formal relationship no you're
talking about like a life coach or
something which yeah i mean life
coaching is [ __ ] this guy i'm
talking about my life when i met him he
said you know i got into civil rights
because of your father he's like i
didn't look up to anyone none of the
famous people just your father he told
the same exact thing to my cousin he
didn't know we were cousins like a year
later because my my uncle's also a civil
rights attorney oh he just does that
yeah interesting dumb [ __ ] a b
yep
[Laughter]
[Music]
anyway let's watch these idiots
why are we adding flame to an already
crazy burning fire and the answer is
just if one baby
is safe from this if one mom chooses to
keep her baby from it then it's all
worth it you know to save babies don't
do a family channel
you want to save kids lives and your
channel now go get a [ __ ] job doing
something else bro
not lying about your kids having cancer
you snake ass [ __ ]
this documentary by no me just trying to
illegalize abortion after this
documentary you're still going to have
the choice yeah you're still going to
have your choice but i know that there's
not in texas
right
yeah
do you hear about the horrible story of
that woman yes i did do you hear the
update about it it was dropped
because she didn't actually even get an
abortion sheet you want to tell the
story yeah this is so [ __ ] up dude
texas is literally [ __ ] medieval ages
it's so insane yeah this woman got
arrested for having abortion because
they just passed that law recently that
essentially outlaws it outside of the
first like three weeks or something yeah
and everyone in the state can sue her
for 10 000 now too right uh and so they
arrested her held her in jail and
everything and um and now uh it got
dropped because they found out that she
it was a stillbirth she didn't even have
an abortion so imagine this woman
going through the trauma
of losing her child and then getting
thrown in jail yeah it's like she gave
the most [ __ ] she gave birth to a
stillborn child which is so
scary and terrifying and traumatic and
then in texas the good people of texas
the god-fearing people of texas threw
her in jail because they suspected she
had an abortion how long was she in jail
for like three weeks or something
i i don't know i'd have to look up she
was actually in jail for a minute i know
she was held for a minute yeah and
they're like whoops
god damn rascal god damn it yeah
in texas we ain't got no taxes boy what
the heck in dog
yeah texas is a [ __ ] nightmare anyone
who's moving there being like texas is
great
texas is [ __ ] medieval
i mean there's lots of good people that
live there not not to hate on our texans
but i'm just saying the state government
there is [ __ ] bro yeah
they're sick [ __ ]
freaks they're mentally ill religious
zealots that are better off
[ __ ] in the 1500s than 2022.
let them secede god damn darn garnet
darn it i swear these these people these
people they have more they're more
common with isis than they do
me
in texas we ain't got no taxes
and our women need permission to leave
the house yeehaw
can i get an amen for texas
[Applause]
we ain't got no texas down here in texas
but if you give an abortion you go into
jail yeehaw and the doctor
we have we have abortion activists that
steal fetuses from
was that in texas the the activists that
stole fetuses uh
no actually i don't think it was yeah
we still that's why it was crazy too
though talking about the one where they
found like a bunch of fetuses yeah there
was a anti-abortion activist that was
stealing fetuses from hospitals
come on now piggy oh hell yeah brother
in texas we like to take women who have
abortions and throw them in the rodeo
and treat them like cattle
star spo it's pretty law
it's [ __ ] up dog
[Music]
they act like women just do abortions
for fun
it's awesome
anyway let's watch
so this is basically these people are
that one mom watching maybe five maybe
ten maybe a hundred maybe a thousand we
have no
idea that
you don't give a [ __ ] about those kids
bro cool effects
they do
they give a [ __ ] about them when they
before they're born
but well exactly that's the real irony
with all of these not all but most
anti-abortion activists is that they're
heavily conservative and they don't
believe in actually taking care they
don't want uh after-school plans no they
don't want free meals
the second you are out of that one day
you better start pulling yourself up
from your booth they don't want to help
care your own individual that baby has
every right to be born into abject
poverty exactly
and to die of
malnutrition
it seems like nobody wants to work these
can i get a man
nobody wants to work
these moms out here just have an
abortion for fun damn
my favorite hobby is having abortions i
like to get pregnant and have an
abortion it's so much fun
nice to know all the resources out there
and also for us as a church and just
just me and cole even just that how much
more we need to be doing we want to go
into this finding out what resources are
available for women that you might not
know about are there resources you know
in your city if not is there something
that the church should be doing that you
watching should be doing maybe you
aren't pregnant maybe you aren't the one
facing the question of what i've been
filming this documentary we've been
asked by her i know this whole
documentary is obviously centered around
the mom and her baby but obviously
there's a father there's a father
somewhere dad right and everyone men
should decide
the man should decide if that baby get
born or not
yeah you having that baby girl
hey guess what dudes that's why you
gotta wear a [ __ ] condom because once
that baby
is conceived
you ain't get a choice no more boy
unfortunately
in some cases
but that's just the way it is
dory's the father was absent the man was
absent and and he's just not involved he
takes a back seat takes a step back
it's just easier that way you know it's
hard unlike me i put my kids on camera
i put my kids on camera and
by the way this is oh [ __ ] i saw this
this is the guy bro look at this sweet i
may just wait 20 years for david
beckham's three-year-old daughter
because god knows she's gonna be
gorgeous god damn this guy does care
about the kids he cares a lot
cares a lot
what yo
how do you tweet that
i'm about to wait 20 years
that is [ __ ] up
that three-year-old girl about making me
feel some type of way
jesus christ
damn bro that's some crazy [ __ ] right
there boy
wait he's not the biological dad
no that's uh i don't know if it's both
the kids or if it's just one but it's
nice biological
that's interesting
um
damn you ever see a three-year-old and
be like damn about to make me act up
well he has
that man has
that man right there he has done that in
fact god fury man in fact he even
expressed that publicly
on a social media platform
to take a step forward and say wow i
wasn't prepared for this i wasn't ready
but i'm going to be here with you i'm
going to rally with you it's already
hard enough as is for a mom to do this
let alone being alone
so i feel like as men
we need to step up we need to rise to
the occasion whenever something that
maybe seems unfortunate and difficult at
the time could come to be one of the
greatest blessings in your life
after walking in to embrace grace and
talking with amy ford and seeing their
team and hearing all the resources
available i just felt so encouraged and
so relieved that like wow people are
being the front runners people are doing
this because you think why aren't people
doing more what why isn't there enough
why isn't there this i know that this
whole documentary is obvious
uh where's the holocaust part yeah
oh it's at the beginning let's just
watch this video
this is great man these guys are awesome
[Music]
one week
three weeks
four weeks
six weeks
seven weeks
oh [ __ ] bro
sounds like the beginning of dark side
of the moon yeah why is this like giving
me like existential
space dread
goes right into breathe
[Music]
abortion has been arguably the most
polarizing heated and controversial
civil rights issues since 1973 when
abortion was legalized in the us
why they do a money sign
like people are making money from
abortions it's big abortion
did that
yeah they did a money sign and the
current supreme court which had nothing
to do with that it was legalized in the
us
getting that big
money
god damn it that big abortion
yeah this is the court by this court is
trying to make it illegal so i don't
even know why you're showing them
[Applause]
there is so much passion on either side
of the topic and seems to be no middle
ground and virtually no humane
conversations
jesus
so much anger and so much hate
in the midst of it all we truly believe
that love is the answer
instead of pro-life so much from anger
so much hate who's the one that's angry
who's the one that's hating who are the
people that blow up the [ __ ] abortion
clinics and kill abortion doctors and
harass people outside the clinic and
call it murder all coming from your side
yeah stupid [ __ ] you minded your
own [ __ ] business there'd be no
problem yeah
like so much hate
big abortion baby
yo actually i heard the guy that
invented abortion gets a kickback every
time there's an abortion
yeah yeah he has a copyright on abortion
he gets a kickback
a rothschild i believe it was
or george soros i think george soros
gets a dollar every time there's an
abortion that's why he's so rich yeah
that's important very few people know
that board abortions
it's actually very lucrative the
abortion business you wouldn't guess it
is it possible for us to be
pro-love
is it possible for us to love both the
mother and the baby i'm actually
anti-love yeah that's my stance
love is
the love is the primary cause of all of
the world's problems actually yeah i'm
i'm pro i am anti-love actually
all right so this is the part that
really ruffled people's feathers
is it possible for us to be
pro-love
is it possible for us to love both the
mother and the baby
so rwanda genocide
cambodian genocide
isn't either or the holocaust of course
and by the way to show kids these poor
kids in a concentration camp you gotta
be [ __ ] kidding me no they're not
zach they're dead serious or
but rather both
there it is
i have my personal look at all that
george soros kickbacks
you have yours
we're all so different what is this
music choice for this too it's a bizarre
so this is not the right vibe at all
62 million abortions
so basically the the holocaust was like
a was like a circus dropping a bucket
yeah nothing
the holocaust i mean that's literally
their point yeah that is like you think
the holocaust was bad [ __ ]
the holocaust was like a trip to
disneyland compared to this [ __ ] no
problem cakewalk man
why even complain
where is god's heart at
where is the truth and peace god
all the chaos and lies
we want to go on a journey to find out i
like how he's like
there's people on both sides and
everyone's so passionate well anyway
they're [ __ ] wrong
the truth
and to find out how we could actually
help and make a difference instead of
just adding more noise to an already
deafening discussion
why is he talking like that it's really
bothering me dude it's like i'm not here
to be offensive but the holocaust was a
[ __ ] joke
compared to this let that base drop on
that 808.
[Music]
dirty ass beat
so weird
i'm not here to offend anyone but the
holocaust was a [ __ ] cakewalk in fact
i doubt it even happens
[Laughter]
planned parenthood bomb planned
parenthood i'm not here to be offensive
but bomb planned
parenthood look at all the gravestones
what the [ __ ] is that dude
so he shows planned parenthood and then
a graveyard i wonder what he's trying to
say
[Music]
gosh i love that that hardcore intro and
then just these two bozos sitting there
pull up that tweet again hey badass
remember this when you said you want
you've seen a three-year-old made you
want to [ __ ]
so yeah
shut up dude
hey dude remember this tweet
i may just wait 20 years for david
beckham's three-year-old daughter
because girl knows you're going to be
gorgeous
hey cole you ever see a three-year-old
and think how bad you want to [ __ ] her
because you actually do that's what you
tweeted there
so that's an interesting take
so what if you're watching this and
you're thinking should i keep my baby
even though it's too hard
as a matter of fact i was in that
position i was 19 when i got pregnant
with everly by the way they they these
these activists what they don't say
is that they're against abortion in all
situations and incest and r word
um and they basically just focus on
these examples of women that
doesn't really exist where it's like
it's just you want an abortion because
it's going to be hard and you don't want
the responsibility i mean you
having an abortion is like
not an easy decision people are not
making this decision lightly
it's not a fun thing that people want to
do just as a contraceptive and i mean
it's probably
coming from their own experience because
it's like oh i got pregnant when i was
still 19 or whatever
um
and you know
i wanted to keep i wanted to go to
college and keep partying um
but you know what
it's not a big deal because
i
come from a middle-income family to
high-income family with a big support
network and you know it worked out for
me it worked out for me just fine my
parents uh you know can watch the baby
while you know i'm going and doing
things or whatever and it's like that's
not everybody's situation i mean the
real heinous thing about this is this
they're wanting to force a 13 year old
girl who was r-worded by her dad to keep
a baby yep that's that's that's that's
that's evil i mean i don't know what to
tell you
and the the laws in texas that they're
rolling out in all the other red states
is like you have like what is it like
six weeks to get an abortion and i mean
most women don't even know they're
pregnant until four or five weeks yeah i
mean it's obviously done in a way in
which the vast vast majority of the time
like 95 percent of
of women who get an abortion don't even
know
basically until like you're [ __ ] with
six weeks you're [ __ ] right
you know and then the other thing they
do is they characterize people who are
pro-choice
like they go you can did you know you
can abort a baby at nine mo one hour
before it's born no you can't you
literally can't do that anywhere and
nobody's in favor of that that's also
barbaric but it's not real right in most
places it's like what five months or
something or like a second trimester yes
it's you know third
third trimester is when it's not allowed
and so yeah so three months of it yeah
like we agree that there's a point where
it's
barbaric to do that
and um
it's nobody's doing abortions one hour
before birth that's [ __ ] insane and
that's how they characterize it right
you guys are sick dude these people are
[ __ ]
and i remember just being so scared i
didn't know what i was gonna do i was
actually in school in college and i
didn't i was too scared to tell my
family i was too scared to tell my
friends it was just a lot for me to take
in being so young i remember those
moments just being so
terrified of just like what the future
would look like what my life was going
to look like
um just so much my sorority party and
now and now i get to use my kids to to
become millionaires right and to exploit
their labor yeah
literally my kids labor for money
[ __ ] literally doing that turned out
such a good call
god damn they suck they're like dude you
sure you want to get that abortion
because i'm telling you man there's a
good roi on those kids
just make a youtube channel
that moment and just knowing how hard it
was gonna be
but ultimately in the end how worth it
it was gonna be looking back now
um literally great she's like i'm rich
literally personally my choice was
always to keep my baby but i also know
that for others there are choices
[Music]
she's
alive she's alive
at the end
again you're not really addressing this
is just an emotional appeal you're not
addressing the real issues right
[Music]
[Music]
i dare you to show them like [ __ ] on
the floor and throwing food and stuff
they'd be like i wish that kid never was
born
[Music]
in america
over 2 000
abortions happen every day
[Music]
every day in america
100 people die in car
accidents 1300 people die from smoking
is that real is there that many
abortions
i think they must be lumping in
stuff that isn't really an abortion
there's no [ __ ] way i believe that
that there's more abortions than car
accidents and cigarette smoke deaths
they said hello you gotta fact check
that every day in america
100 every four 2
363 abortions a day
seems maybe plausible i don't know it
doesn't seem
well if you compare it to car crashes
and cigarettes they're saying in america
or worldwide no in america yeah okay
[Music]
are they counting plan b that someone
said no way
no that can't include plan b
do they think plan b is abortion
i think so
what
plan b's a portion i don't know if they
do personally i i know some
plan b
activists are
the hell
every day in america
100 people die in car accidents
1300 people die from smoking
1800 people die from heart disease
the leading cause of death in the u.s
according to the cdc
[Music]
so according to them our death stat
should be leading cause of deaths of
americans one abortion
that is what they're trying to say yeah
another
even more deadly killer than heart
disease damn
by definition
abortion is when a pregnancy is ended so
that it doesn't result in the birth of a
child
so as we've been filming this
documentary we've been asked by our
friends by family by mentors why are we
mentor alert there's so much at risk why
are we even making this why are we
adding flame to an already
crazy burning fire and the answer is
just if one baby
is safe from this if one mom chooses to
keep her baby from it then it's all
worth it this documentary by no means
just trying to illegalize abortion after
this documentary you're still gonna have
the choice yeah you're still gonna have
your choice but i know that there's
gonna be one mom watching maybe five
maybe ten maybe a hundred maybe a
thousand we have no
idea the ripple effects but just for you
guys to know all the resources out there
and also for us as i hope he saves a
baby that comes and robs him in 20 years
that'd be awesome he goes we have no
idea that ripple effects some kid 20
years who got saved from this video is
going to come stab him
the church and just
just saying
me and cole even just that how much more
we need to be doing we want to go into
this finding out what resources are
available for women that you might not
know about are there resources you know
in your city if not is there something
that the church should be doing no
because they've all been defunded
yeah i don't know what he's talking
about oops let's see what's probably
just church yeah you need to go to
church and beg for help from the church
yeah they just need to listen to uh
brenda's got a baby by tupac
it wouldn't drive me up the walls
as much i mean i i'm still pro-choice
obviously but if these same people
weren't
the exact
same set of people that are like gutting
all of the infrastructure and support
systems and safety nets these
freeloaders yeah i don't think i think
going forever
i think these single moms need to get
their ass to work
right
literally like
it's crazy so crazy
get your [ __ ] ass up and work
she should be doing maybe you aren't
pregnant maybe you aren't the one facing
the question of whether i'm gonna have
an abortion or not but you're thinking
what more can i do what how can i better
help how can i better stand with these
women for these women
so we're going into this thinking how
can we help more what more can we do and
i'm excited to find out yeah
me too what happens during an abortion
in private practice i prefer
yeah i don't think anyone's ever covered
this topic before
so what is an abortion formed
just under 1200 abortions including
first and second they're like this guy
bro this guy thinks they think this
guy's killed 1200 people
pretty much justify doing anything to a
guy like that he's killed 1200 people
it's like the most prolific serial
killer of all time
right it's actually dangerous to be an
abortion doctor
trimester abortions up to 24 weeks of
gestation
so i feel like one of the most important
questions that everybody asks is when
does life begin and if we had a direct
answer then i feel like this wouldn't
even be
a conversation because if we could all
agree that life began at a certain point
then abortion should be allowed before
that dumb [ __ ] you know what you think
conception is when life begins you know
that's when you think
and not allowed after in your
professional opinion when when would you
say life begins
it's such a simple question with such a
complicated answer
a human
egg is fertilized by a sperm and that
whoa not safe for work single cell
organisms they just showed a cream pie
dude on youtube
i was looking at my screen and i missed
it watch this is so this is it actually
lewd or are you kidding no i'm serious
look at this
a human
egg is fertilized by a
a
sperm
cell organism
that has a unique
genetic
makeup
that is the first
so at fertilization you have a living
cell
that has that unique genetic pattern so
on that basis human life begins at
fertilization
yeah
but a lot happens after that it gets
complicated but
i really do believe that a human life
that human life that individual
human being with that unique genetic
signature starts at fertilization can
you actually ask a doctor that's not a
member of your church
like no [ __ ] doctor would ever answer
that
life begins at conception
you know i feel like the real scientific
answer is probably when there starts to
be like a brain activity right which i
don't think happens until like you know
six seven
six months or something
so
how about just
it is a being that can exist without
being essentially a parasite to another
human being
yeah
right
six months
i don't know there's a certain point
when there's more brain activity
so i don't people think of doctors as so
smart we're no different than anyone
else
i love this guy people think of doctors
they're so smart we're actually a bunch
of idiots we're [ __ ] idiots man we're
[ __ ] the dumbest we don't know what
we're talking about we're actually not
smarter than
that's why you should listen to
everything i have to say about it i went
to med school in the caribbean for sure
this guy's awesome i love this guy you
know
a lot of people look up to doctors i'm
here to say we are really dumb
in fact you're probably know more about
this than i do
dr [ __ ] chivago
was that the guy that was killing people
dr kevorkian kevor whatever
when you figure out here not here
that killing a baby this big for money
is wrong
it doesn't take you too long to figure
out it
it doesn't matter if the baby dude you
guys are going to talk to a real doctor
at least if you want to have an honest
conversation why are you gonna become
doctor and then preach to me about how
you don't have to be a [ __ ] genius no
killing a baby is wrong
who are you bro
he is this big or this big or even this
big it's all this big
we talk about this big
this big you ever seen a human being
this big before
same
i love what dr levatino said that
whenever we start saying like at what's
can you look up the credentials on that
guy dr levitino whatever i said this
guy's probably a chiropractor
i totally hate him
but also he said he's done 1200
abortions in his life so what the [ __ ]
going on with this guy he's like no it's
murder it's totally murder and i [ __ ]
love it and i love killing yeah i'm
super into it
i don't
here
former
former abortion provider doctor
he came to god
that's probably what's going on here
yeah where'd he get his uh degree
[ __ ] the university uh medical degree
from albany medical college in 1976.
i don't know anything about did science
even exist then
he's cause he's old right yeah
thank you
it's hilarious
size is a human baby it's like well what
size is a human a human you know
whenever you realize that a baby this
big this big and this big as a baby it
doesn't matter if it's this big or this
big
you know like if we're going based off
of size our baby in the womb right now
she said was like as you know the tip of
my finger but we saw a little arms and
legs on our ultrasound the baby was
moving around the baby was moving
dude this is such a dumb [ __ ]
documentary
when does brain activity start can you
look that up
yeah
you know
how is this allowed on youtube dude it's
[ __ ] up
well this whole slant of it being like a
documentary that's trying to examine
both sides is just insane i mean this
this
you know from our perspective this seems
really easy to dunk on and seems insane
i mean
this is
mainstream conservative thought in the
united states period like this is not
even extremist
by any means and so
i mean youtube isn't going to ban this
well like i said texas one of the most
populous states in the country maybe you
know i think it's number three
i mean literally and illegal roe is
probably going away in the next year or
two yeah the process of developing a
brain around week six or seven
and then actual brain activity uh weeks
12 to 16. so there you go i mean the ba
it doesn't even have a [ __ ] brain
until week six or seven
and then brain activity a stretch to
call it a brain at that point it's just
a collection of cells yeah and then when
does brain activity start
um actually i'm seeing conflicting stuff
right here let me just fact check real
quick
[Music]
saying between weeks 12 and 16 i've seen
a lot
12 and 16.
so that would be like three to four
months something like that yeah that
seems reasonable to me like three to
four months gives you enough time
to understand what's going on
the baby is not well formed yet
and um
that seems completely reasonable
to me
yes somebody said my brain activity
didn't even start till i was age 20. so
there you go
mine still hasn't kicked in yeah
coconuts and barbados
but i feel like there's a compromise
here that doesn't include like militant
psycho [ __ ] freak [ __ ] that just
accuse everyone of killing babies like
what does it even have to do with the
bible i don't even know why they had to
bring up this cause this moral panic
it's like i'm pretty sure the bible
doesn't give a [ __ ] about abortion
i don't know i can't speak on that
just chilling with her
we're excited to sit down with dr kathy
altman and hear her story on this topic
you're clearly not going to change
anyone's mind because nobody's buying
this [ __ ] unless they're already in your
um
cult
so i feel like a lot of people watching
or listening might not know how
abortions are performed you know i think
the
you hear pro-choice and it sounds
right because it's like oh well
the mother should be able to decide
whether to keep or not keep but they
don't understand what not keep means
well most people don't realize it but
any ob gyn has to learn how to do
abortions in their residency program you
can opt out because of conscience but i
didn't because i was really
very pro-abortion
i had had an abortion myself
and i didn't think any woman should have
to
bear a child she didn't want
can i get an animals die please uh
animals die
thank you
in our training program we learned how
to do
first trimester abortions but i was so
gung-ho
that i went outside of the program
and got one of the local abortionists
to show me how to do dne abortions which
are also known as dismemberment
abortions
where you okay chill damn this lady's a
[ __ ] murderer they're right
this lady she's like i wanted to learn
how to dismantle babies and the [ __ ] who
were like about to give birth where'd
you find this lady it's nice that she's
able to do to do this interview outside
of prison
murderer
literally take the baby apart piece by
piece to remove it
in the first trimester
that involves um
putting some local anesthetic in the
cervix
and after you
have the opening
you ready for this large enough you
insert a little tube and you go around
just like a little vacuum cleaner and
suck out the
suck out the pregnancy and the
the baby is sort of torn apart as it's
going through the hole because it's
bigger than the hole
and then the placenta
it is it's horrific that it's not an
easy choice that's the point okay
this lady's out in there just killing
babies for fun though
you know what i'm saying
so they compare
anyway
oh he put out a statement about the
backlash
nice
instagram did take our
end feed post down
really
so wait zuckerberg said no and youtube
said good
this is okay fortunately we have talked
with our team at youtube and they're
keeping the documentary up
which is the most important they did
demonetize plus take the video out of
the algorithm which is all okay
we assume this would happen the biggest
thing
this does is significantly reduce the
videos reach the more people
the video reaches the more people we can
find who can find help
this makes it where you can really only
watch the video if you have a link or go
directly to our channel
at this point we'll leave the message in
god's hand and trust that whoever's
supposed to watch it will watch it
you guys have supported this so much and
we're so
thankful nice not really an apology is
that
not more of a statement
well anyway just remember this guy
thinks of having sex when he sees
three-year-olds and he click-baited his
kids having cancer so
uh
the love brand well they have 13 million
subscribers they're huge what on the
[ __ ] yo no wonder they're happy they
kept those kids this guy's rich as hell
here's a kid with the rash clickbaiting
their kid having a rash excellent
their kid's a dancer of course
here is one of uh
our time with jimmy savelle what weird
here they took a tour of neverland ranch
[Music]
surprised that place is still taking
visitors
here he describes that he does um he's
actually a scout a scout captain
which is nice of him to spend time with
the kids like that and do retreats
oh here's the here's the great clickbait
now this is not their kid
look at the title of this one she got
diagnosed with cancer documentary
[ __ ] that's after they change a
thumbnail yeah that's that's the second
one which i don't think is better
yeah these guys are good good people
this is your brain on jesus my friends
jesus is a hell of a drug man
jesus
all right
[Applause]
should we do the bitcoin convention in
miami or keemstar versus xqc
yeah
so keemstar what happened
there's this guy i've speed i show speed
he's 17 years old by the way
and where she is she's on top of that
which makes me a little more sympathetic
for him
no
i'd watch it all the way
anyway this this guy i show speed
he's 17 so you know i guess go easy on
him a little bit
uh
i wasn't this way wait until you see the
other clip
oh there's there's a bunch of them we we
actually you might not remember but we
we talked about one of his clips well
when he goes who's gonna stop me yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
um
but again i do think it's important to
emphasize he's 17 i mean at 17 you're
[ __ ] dumb like literally yeah for
sure
but what's the interesting thing is that
while everyone's dog piling on him he
got banned on twitch and everything you
can always count on keemstar to support
hating women like i i've seen this
without without fail yeah without fail
keemstar comes to his defense and i was
like has keemstar ever defended a woman
ever and i was trying to think i mean i
know he supported trisha when she was
trying to ruin my life
before that that was an alliance of
convenience though yeah he has a tricia
folder right right before that right and
then who else has he defended uh women a
woman he's defended there was someone
else
which women have hated you
what would any woman have ever had a
problem with you right exactly
coming with that heat
oh god
anyway here's the clip so just to catch
you guys up
and where she is she's on top of the
thing
10 seconds 10 seconds
this guy's really popular right yeah
very much though come on
like youtuber or streamer or whatever
love probably knows more than that
i'm not well he was banned from twitch
for the
clip where he essentially threatens to
r-word someone though who's going to
stop me clip right yeah he was banned
from twitch because of that so now he
streams on youtube and he might be on
his way out from youtube as well so gg
well
damn dude you gotta chill yeah and i
already see people pointing out so
this clip that went viral of him that
we're about to watch
uh
there is a
longer clip beforehand where somebody
one of the people that he's yelling at
says something pretty racist to him
okay um and so that's been like kind of
the consistent thing of like it's unfair
you're leaving out the context they were
being racist to him first he was just
reacting or whatever
that's fine if there weren't already
like
multiple clips of the same guy screaming
at women threatening
i've seen it right exactly and he does
that joke all the time he goes if we
were on a desert island would you sleep
with me and she goes nah he says well
who's gonna stop me
yeah i've seen him do that shtick like a
lot
but okay i mean listen
whatever let's watch this so wait
holy you're out the fight
calm down damn bruh shut up bro i know
how to play this game i'm not a noob all
right god damn
[ __ ] dude
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] talking to me is a
female talking to me am i yo no no no am
i tripping am i tripping all right
it's a female talking to me right now
it's a [ __ ] female professor get off
the [ __ ] game and do your whopping
dishes [ __ ]
[ __ ] jesus christ he's so angry for 17.
he's insane i mean it's a stick
i know but he actually well exactly it's
his shtick but when he put out his
apology he said he was talking like that
he was really actually angry oh is there
saying he's 19
i thought someone said he was 17.
[ __ ] is wrong with y'all stop talking to
me like that [ __ ]
[ __ ] is wrong with y'all dog i'm not one
of these little lame ass batman nerds
[ __ ]
yes you are
now
[ __ ] nerds on my [ __ ] team look
like [ __ ] like what [ __ ] you
because if you do a google search it
says 17 the first oh well i don't feel
bad for him if he's 19.
he's a big boy
well
i'm getting there's no
website saying 17 half st 19. you're
saying 17 and 19. 17. let's go with 18.
i saw let's just average it out yeah i
saw a lot of people saying he's 17.
i would assume he's above 18 because all
these
twitch streamers has had him on
like doing weird [ __ ] and i'm sure they
would not put themselves in a situation
where he's underaged i'm not sure about
that well
yeah
i i think it might be the case
his birthday is january 21st 2005
uh according to wikipedia which makes
him how old
uh seven that would be the seventeen i
think he's seventeen yeah
wikipedia though i gotta like a
psychological question okay
see if we're the last two people on
earth and we had to reproduce to make
the world continue
with
reproducing
no because that means our kids will have
to intertwine and then their kids no
who gonna stop me
i will who's gonna stop me
i will if we're the last two people i
like how she's like she's right because
he's like [ __ ] he's very small
she's like i will
yeah
who gonna stop me
you're not stopping me
if we're the last two people on earth
hold up hold up chill out chill out just
even nathan ross is like uh hold on
you're good oh africa oh i'm tripping so
yikes
that's his whole stick i guess and
whatever you think about him
he put out an apology which i thought
was decent and he's a young man whatever
it's obviously he's [ __ ] disturbed
i think it's really bad for people to
see that and think it's funny whatever
okay the point is is that there's a 40
year old man named keemstar out
defending it
it was like that's the really [ __ ] up
yeah forget about i speed whatever
so this tweet went viral of this guy
jake lucky who's like a news reporter
um more of a commentator commentator so
he he tweeted out this clip
i understand why valorant queues are so
unbelievably toxic you got one of the
most popular streamers on youtube i show
speed saying crap like this and getting
nothing but praise and laughs crap is
whack
i think he's he's right you he should be
calling out this kind of behavior
obviously it's going to have an
influence on the game and the players
so i think he did the right thing
calling this out you know bring it to
people's attention
it went super viral though 185 000 likes
uh should i watch his apology
what's good um he apologized to the girl
and he apologized to the guy
it's a clip you know oh he says he's 17
in the video basically his apology is
like i'm 17 guys give me a break which
okay whatever
but
you know keemstar then shows up to
defend
i show speed that implies
the guy that tweeted it out is being
racist check this out
keemstars who's against woke culture by
the way
so keemstar hates this guy jake sucky
because he's
in the same space space doesn't have a
racist past yeah stuff along those lines
so he goes so jake sucky tried to expose
i show speed for quote trash talk in
video games we found some really
hypocritical tweets from him many are
saying jake lucky's attack was racially
motivated
many are saying
that's something that's
such a like little
trumpism right there the keemslide
that's what i call it everybody's
talking about it everybody's saying i
didn't say your wife looks like a horse
i didn't say your wife looks like a
witch by the way the stuff he did dig up
is like totally
yeah cod trust it's totally not
hypocritical or contrary
the guy is like squeaky clean
um
oh you got all the screenshots so here's
keem's tweet
and then xqc comes in
it says apparently keemstar seems to
think that is a female talking to me get
off the game and do your and do your
wash and do your dishes is good trash
talk
or even trash talk at all pretty rich to
try to use the racism card while
overlooking blatant sexism stop baiting
women haters getting old xqc said
which i appreciate his willingness to
actually
respond to keemstar most people don't
want to deal with that because of course
keemstar's response to that is to try to
dig up anything and to try to ruin xqc's
life right it's like go as low as
possible
so keemstar makes a video
about uh
what is this screenshot
it's a video okay good yeah
it's not playing okay so i'm on polygon
right now it says overwatch league pro
suspend it for
homophobic remark on live stream
what is going on here
xqc like are you actually a homophobe or
was it just trash talk i'm confused
because like you're trying to insinuate
what speed said
is sexism it's not trash talk right you
you you said it can't be both right it's
not even trash talk right like
so so you're really a homophobe
or were you just talking trash in a game
i'm confused xqc help me out with this
okay so i'm on polygon right now it says
overwatch league pro suspended for
homophobic remark on live stream
what is going on here
xqc what's going on here are you
actually a homophobe or was it just
trash talk
right
so xqc responded
hey yo cockster what up brother
since i thought uh we're making videos
today so i'll make a video just for you
man uh you pulled some article in 2018
and uh you thought i was trying to hide
it or something like that okay this
article i put like every single week to
show my chat that people can change in
three or four years it happens people
can get better as the whole point of it
but also
i'm glad you tweeted every single day to
give us a reminder that people don't
change
sometimes even after 10 15 years
like you man
also give alex a call man i think he's
been looking for you
so i think he actually said it really
good it's like
keemstar's attack on people is always
like well you did this thing in the past
and
he even said once about me like
like how he's proudly never changed
keemstar's probably never changed you
know
i mean we grew up on the internet where
like
racism and homophobia was like
normalized and then if anyone realizes
that that's not the way to be then then
they're uh virtue signaling and keemstar
is just being true to himself as a
racist
uh sexist pig
there you go that's about it
i saw someone say that i'm getting
called out for being homophobic on
twitter and the subreddit
why
well i should address it no if it's
happening i'm not dealing with that [ __ ]
today
i don't see anything though
oh my god
i don't see anything though i don't see
anything yeah i mean
someone said come on you talking about
power bottom is like me asking ela
if she likes it from the front or back
does she ride your [ __ ] or does she like
you to pound her [ __ ] from the back
well if we were having a conversation
about that and she called in to talk
about it
you know
then that's fine
so there you go
keemstar i thought there was more stuff
by keemstar
about it he was going on and all quite a
bit wasn't he
and defensive speed
uh and attacking that guy jake
let me just switch twitter accounts so i
could check
let's see because you're blocked yep
yeah
ride my dick
can't wait to report your death
uh
yeah baby
so we got to talk about joe biden versus
bts this guy
has three hours i think maybe we should
wait isn't it in the title james oh no
it's not james charles where's the
diaper and lebron found we go three
hours yep it's five already
the [ __ ] did that happen
been streaming for the past three hours
hold on i really wanted to talk about
the damn
first of all we need to make it clear
here today that everybody throw it up
i'll throw it up right now guys get
those hearts up for bts let them know
put it up dan i told you i'm a cancelled
dad black pink fan no i'm a black pig
you got you don't have to choose dan you
can love them both
put it up or you're dead they're gonna
come hold the [ __ ] heart out they're
coming dan
they're coming stop being a [ __ ]
rebel just hold it up not doing it put
it up then
i'm panicking
put it up all right fine whatever then
pretty
thank god i was sweating i was like damn
don't do this
you gotta put it up
well joe budden
he said some [ __ ] about bts have we
found out has he been cancelled yet is
his life ruined yet or not yeah well he
went through it he made it a apology
yeah he did oh yeah you know i the
minute i saw this i was like oh hell no
so this is actually i haven't seen his
apologies so this should be fun
but
i hate them bts [ __ ] uh oh no you all
in there i've wowed yo there's people
there that know he's like
i'll walk that back
he's like you better walk that back
quick
they tried to stop him
four okay we know i want no smoke tell
me why
they sound good the music ain't bad oh
they're like they sound too good he's
like
winking at them
they're too good they're like the
producer's like
why would you hate bts the music is
awesome the guys are sweet
they're just it's beautiful just
incredible i mean there's nothing really
even a bad thing to say about the guys
great sound sounds great
super talented to dancing is incredible
you know what i'm saying bad it's just
sound i mean
tell me why though
do i need a reason yeah come on you
should you don't have a reason
if you don't have a reason that's
disgusting this guy's just realizing he
[ __ ] up and homies
you don't have a reason that's
disgusting yeah
yo they're throwing itself his ass right
under the bus i hate them [ __ ] oh
there's no reason why i hate them
i don't have to divulge my reasons dude
i just hate them [ __ ] then why'd you
say it though it's like he's bailing
he's bailing
i don't want to hear that [ __ ] i don't
want to see them dance moves i don't
want to see you come down from the sky
in the little uh uh umbrella i don't
want to see your fork [ __ ] uh your
four codies come from the audience and
then link up like vote trying to do all
the [ __ ] 98 degrees moves i don't want
to see none of this [ __ ] i don't want to
see it i know they big i know it's china
i don't want to see i don't want it's
not china
you say i know it's china
oh no
that's bad oh
that's bad
i don't want to see korea but korea i
don't want to see korean sync
i don't want to see korean sync why does
he say sync he's saying like insane
korea saying oh korea sync
okay
why y'all think what this is this is uh
i said joe button pretty soon you go to
hell yeah joe budden
joe biden joe budden you go to hell
why do y'all think that because
a group is big or an act is big and
they're talented that you can't hate
them
to in my opinion dog if you don't reason
if yeah if you just don't like somebody
for no reason that's disgusting
oh my god this guy knows exactly what
he's doing
you're a hater you're player hating
but i like how he
goes he like he's talking way too strong
like i feel like he goes that's
disgusting yeah
somebody just walking around like yo i'm
like joe budd and i don't like parks and
i'm like yo where what they did to you
if it makes sense what why you don't
like them cool if it don't make sense yo
get the [ __ ] away from me oh my god bro
that's your dude right there he's coming
he's literally through him the guy went
home he told his wife to pack everything
up get the kids
getting out of here yo he threw his ass
in a pit it just [ __ ] bailed on him
left him to stew in that nuclear tank
why don't you like don't have to
necessarily do something you don't have
a reason but if you got no reason at all
and it's just like i don't want anything
like that [ __ ] i don't want to see that
[ __ ] i don't necessarily enjoy the
politics
behind that [ __ ]
like what
i can't think of a less political one
well also like i know there's a lot of
things about how like the k-pop culture
is corporate and stuff but he clearly
doesn't know anything about k-pop so i
think he's not referring to that yeah no
trying to say people
acting like they like them so that
people are afraid to talk about them
basically
i think so based on
watching more of this based off of the
way that you're acting a minute ago you
might be right
dan's that guy the guy who's saying
that's disgusting he's your dan yeah
yeah i know dan will throw me under the
bus
no but i don't think he knows anything
about it [ __ ] out of you he's about to
find out i feel like shaq when yao man
started defending the all-star game
[Laughter]
[ __ ] pop star dancing
over here blowing up being shoved in my
face at every award wait what's he
saying oh he think no he's saying it's a
pc thing
it's like a cultural like look at the
well and he's also saying like why
aren't there other k-pop groups that are
there
yeah and there's a ton and they they're
black pink forever exactly i'm
personally bts army i like black pink
too
but i think what he's saying is that
it's a political thing to make like an a
korean band popular it's like a tokenism
thing yeah
that seems to be what he's saying board
show i mean that's the thing about award
shows the people that's there are shoved
in my face every award show so it's
dozia i love her though it's bts it's
lil nas x it's billy eilish it's chris
stapleton i'm pretty sure you dropped it
you're just describing pop star exactly
the popular acts yeah
he's like what's with these award shows
with all these popular acts
it's like what do you expect to see
there
it's these are the people that are
shoved in my face and at some point
yeah you're gonna say oh [ __ ] some of
these [ __ ] nah nah if the music is
trash if the music is trash and i'm i
ain't beat but if the music is all right
then i'm cool with it they deserving it
yeah this guy's reading chat right now
you could tell
he's like [ __ ] this joe budden guy i
never liked him
as long as the music dope and these
[ __ ] music is i i'm sorry
like i've heard a couple i didn't even
know it was them i'm like who the [ __ ]
is these bts [ __ ] i keep saying
everywhere and when you're there i
played the record i went through that
same thing i went through this
track so i was like oh there's all and
that's politics
do you have your computer i want to see
how many pts songs you have
[Laughter]
then how is it not politics you just
said that that's not isis it's not
something shelved in my face i didn't
say that you said that i never said it
you just did you started playing music
and i was like yo no i kept hearing the
name bts and i'm like who the [ __ ] is
bts and then somebody played this then i
heard the song oh [ __ ] i heard this i
just never knew it was this move like
butter
i got bts on my phone
joe biden's dead like a turkey
on thanksgiving
very
well you always in a club with bts came
on
see that's why i don't club with y'all
skinny girls just dancing to k-pop i
said yo
joe i just mentioned a rapper i'd be
like who the [ __ ] is that he'd be like
you know the song and then he'll play
the song or the song will come on he'd
be like i'll be like oh that's them
these bts [ __ ] got slaps a bunch of
them yeah that's all look at this trash
[ __ ] trash
all right so now
let's fast forward to the apology
because you got to love how confident he
is and all that and then army comes for
his ass
uh oh
fast forward to an army come for the boy
yeah they
reportedly responded
exactly oh dude yeah one of the band
members what's his name rmrm rm
responded and then i was like oh [ __ ]
he's dead because i have never seen them
respond to a hater like this it's the
next clip in the dark dude i was like
joe biden got called out he's [ __ ]
dead
outside his head intentionally calling
him joe biden over and over again
yeah he's just
go bud
i was like there's vt the army's outside
his house with rocket launchers and [ __ ]
at this moment
so r.m from bts responded um he didn't
say his name but everyone assumed he was
talking to him um
they have their right to hate but if it
was me i'd rather just talk with my
friends
[Applause]
[Music]
that's pretty crazy i've never seen him
do like that before
so everyone's like yo what yo what upset
rm
why is rm upset right now
i swear there's like a whole speed army
swat team outside his house bro when i
looked up hashtag joe budden this
weekend the first thing was army we have
a new enemy oh
just a picture of his face
yeah that was not a fun week when i was
a new army enemy
i was public enemy number one for like a
minute there
i hey bro this is it this is me to the
army
truce
so he made an apology
oh [ __ ] they're back in the same set
here we go
characters bro holy [ __ ]
but i only listen i have all the respect
in the world for the bts didn't sound
like it the other week
that's not what you're saying last time
dude
uh-uh
fans because outside of y'all that took
the opportunity to start calling me a
[ __ ]
man holy [ __ ] the rest of y'all were
so polite in your grievance with me and
for that round of applause man
whatever oh yeah
[Applause]
what did i say last week no no no no i
love bts
respect
all it takes is a music take to bring
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] house
somebody did that for him
yes there's hateful people in the world
and i understand
his homies still riding for beat this
he's like no army wouldn't say that
you're lying
listen i apologize i i'll be the first
to admit to my ignorance i didn't know
the k in front of k-pop was for korea
dumbass that's actually really dumb
didn't know that he thought they're from
china
that's bad
how would i know that yeah
i get how you would they don't ever say
korean pop they just call it k-pop
i don't know what the k stands for
i didn't know that either what else none
of them knew that what else would it
stand for yeah they're they're korean
for cool with a k
for kuwait kuwait pop wait pop well
that's a q
no okay okay
you're thinking of guitar
guitar yeah k-pop
i don't think that
should be funny i know that but i do
want to apologize to the people that
only saw that clip for my ignorance um
you understand it there
uh y'all was teaching me words to call
me a xenophobe i had no idea what that
was i had to look it up sorry
you knew what that was
hello you yeah he this guy's staying
right that guy's so good he's so smart
he's smart he's like i'm not saying [ __ ]
about nothing of course i do
of course
of course
he's
i mean to be fair i feel like at his age
you should know what xenophobic is
right
yeah it's a
pretty common pretty commonly used word
[Laughter]
he's still reading chat
and somebody said what are we going to
teach how to
whistle said your whistle is trash
i would never say that about him because
i can't whistle for nothing that was one
of the things i failed at trying to do
when i was just younger sarcastic
whistle i'm not out here trying to be
[ __ ] but you could if you wanted to
let him know you can get a good whistle
off if you want it
oh my god that sounds horrible get it
back on with the apology bro you would
not
it's like or prejudice i don't know
against people from other countries oh
my god i don't think that what that says
is that yeah
well you said they're chinese so it's a
little of that a little bit of that yeah
a little bit at all you know they just
find the worst [ __ ] they never what
happened to just my bad you know i made
a mistake i didn't know
they just always go right to the worst
possible thing you could be right a
xenophobe
my bad don't exist no more though like i
didn't know my fault i wasn't trying to
intent don't matter yeah today fam most
of that [ __ ] was ingested and fun
anyway this dude was like anyone who
says that's a [ __ ] republical freak
anyone who says k-pop sucks is a [ __ ]
violent
freakish [ __ ] podcast around that
part too well that's what we're doing
but we constantly all right
because y'all know we quick to say
you can't
somebody can take it how they want that
is true so yeah it wasn't just but
that's why somebody might not take it in
just that's true
i agree that's all dude they came down
hard on him
last week he's like i just hate him
it's politics
everybody hate him
come on y'all y'all know what i meant
i p i come in peace
today to the army yeah to the bts legion
of man you gotta give him some dynamite
or something there that's what you got i
gotta give him something right yeah you
gotta give him something
that's that's your that's our peace
offering yeah my sleeper today
there you go there you go there you go
give him a burst or something
there you go i don't know pretty funny
it's pretty funny just seeing
the the inevitable life cycle of a bts
hater
you know they get taught real quick
i'll tell you what man
you got we got to send the bts fandom
out to like the streets of chicago or
some [ __ ] to just or detroit or whatever
they just
these people know how to keep [ __ ] in
line
i'm just saying man they're very
organized they're organized
you know they they know how to keep [ __ ]
and control you got to drop army on
[ __ ] ukraine and clean up
the whole situation there
that's funny
anyway shout outs you know love them
bts forever can't wait for the new album
right guys oh yeah
i didn't know that they had more music
on the way well you know they always do
do they oh yeah they're always pumping
it out oh yeah
it's crazy because every single song is
amazing
it's like the beatles in that way yeah
cause you look back at the beatles
they're like wow every song that album
is like a classic it's the same thing
yeah they're saying army thinks bts
could drop their new album in may
hell yeah wow so soon i'm so excited so
that's what i'm super pumped for oh
and i'm sure joe budden is right there
with me we'll have a listening party
together sure
smooth like butter tastiness undercover
you know he didn't used to eat my
popcorn with butter but now i do since
that time
i like but i love butter now
no chance that you didn't even
republican with butter
bacon
tonight oh
anyway
there you go guys
keep up forever bts forever
all right we've been going for a long
last time yes indeed so do you guys like
the title james charles where's the
diaper and the lebran family or do you
guys think the lebron family is more
trending
i don't think anybody cares about james
charles to be frank
can we do a poll
let's do a poll before we wrap it up
sure what is the
best headline the brandt family
james charles wearing a diaper or there
was another one we did that was pretty
good oh xqc versus keemstar
keemstar usually does pretty good for us
people hate his guts
or
bts or keemstar so we have james charles
diaper
oh bts yeah bts is an option
bts versus joe budden or something
rip joe button what
what did i say something wrong no no no
why you look at me like i'm just saying
i don't know about the bts one
right well let's see what the people say
what's the best headline
black bruno someone said
yeah i'm sure they'll get lots of clicks
i'm feeling personally the lebrant
family is pretty heavily trending but
let's see what the people say
what would you be most interested in
that's what i want you to vote for
okay james charles wearing a diaper and
a heavy lead right out the gate but we
need more votes what the [ __ ] i gotta
agree with the james shaw as well
there you go you see these polls are
great we shoot this at the end of every
episode okay
you can't just let it slide please
basically vote based on which one you
would click on you know which story
interests you the most i love you all
for clicking jim shows where's the
diaper
well it's good too because we already
have the thumbnail for that so this
uh yeah
[ __ ]
so there you go the brandt family
yeah james charles and a diaper has
taken a commanding lead the james the
james haters have it
let me do this at the end of every
episode this is great this is really
good
this is great
so
info
james charles wears a diaper james
charles wears diapers
james charles caught wearing a diaper or
just james charles where's the diaper
and the lebron family i think that's a
great title
all right guys thanks for voting thanks
for being here
apologies to whatever his name was
apparently i was homophobic to him
but uh whatever what can you do
we're navigating the space together
right guys
i learned what's a power bottom though
for being homophobic to the caller
that's what
i don't think i just saw a comment but i
don't think it's really no where are you
looking at the comments in the middle of
the show what are you doing
what are you doing i just yeah i don't
know whatever
let's see
people say it was gross and
disappointing
saying you can guess if matt is a power
bottom by his voice is so gross but i
was right that was the point
wasn't i he admitted yeah of course you
were right and
honestly just so over these [ __ ]
people shut the [ __ ] up shut up
i mean i was just trying to make the
call fun yes it's a [ __ ] entertaining
show shut the [ __ ] up someone says i
don't know what's up so disappointing
someone said grow up jesus christ
i don't know what's up with ethan today
but something's off bad vibes this
episode shut the [ __ ] up unsubscribe go
away
jesus christ
someone said i remember now they're
going back i remember ethan also asked
contra points if she
had gotten bottom surgery and she had to
explain
it wasn't any of his business and that's
not a question you should randomly ask a
trans person it wasn't a random question
it was actually an interview and i asked
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
how dare i try to learn about the
yeah and she said that it was okay yeah
specifically said
just so you know that's not an
appropriate question to ask any trans
person but i'm happy to answer it
doesn't bother me
and that was an edited episode and if it
was uncomfortable we would have taken it
out well i actually learned a lot from
her yeah so just
someone said i think ethan feels
this is just the thread where everyone's
playing just well it's good i think it's
good to address it now it's how how many
times you get the opportunity all right
to get into a controversy and then
respond to it in the same episode don't
have to [ __ ] talk about it next time
someone said it sometimes feels like
ethan thinks lgbtq plus people are
exotic or something it's super uncomfy
yeah i think you all need to [ __ ]
do you think it's hard for a straight
person to understand how it feels
to always have people define you by how
you prefer sex
is that a valid criticism
no because again we
it's the
is the context
this is a loose
comedy show okay like it's
ethan
whole persona
is being a bit of a goof that's why you
guys watch
like
it just oh my god
so you're just unlocking me now way more
than you're getting stun locked like i'm
so [ __ ] frustrated with these people
beat the [ __ ] out so wait what was that
where did it even come what was i saying
who was the power bottom it was the
how do we even get started in that
it was oh james charles being a power
bottom because he was wearing diapers
yeah yes
which is a funny i mean it's funny right
i think so
and so then they said power he called in
to talk about power bottom so i don't
know how it's always to define them
about sex that was literally the context
of the conversation
i know to say if you think i'm not an
ally then like
if you think i'm not a lgbtq plus ally
then
how can you be
i mean
i don't mean for you to be no
you should never ask questions you
should you should treat them as pariahs
you should and and always tiptoe around
everything especially in the context of
a comedy show you should
never ask questions and you should never
joke around and treat people as equals
by the way respect matt i'm glad he
called in we had a conversation that was
great no problem no hate at all on that
i mean he didn't seem offended either
yeah i don't know i do think some of
y'all are way too [ __ ] sensitive for
the show to be just to be totally honest
like people in this thread who are
saying they're grossed out and whatever
i think you're really i think this with
peace and love you might be too
sensitive to watch this show yep
before i started here a long time ago as
a fan i saw a white guy make a video
saying ethan klein islamophobic because
you made a joke once about doing a bar
dab
which i found hilarious me and my wife
muslim fans who have watched this show
forever we found that hilarious that a
white dude was getting mad we laughed at
that joke
white dude's getting mad
i don't even remember the joke but i
could see myself doing that
but it's just like anyone who watches
you should know like you it's a comedic
podcast like dan said like
and i mean we're pretty pc in general
too
like it's a comedy podcast but i feel
like we are pretty respectful
at the same time
um
so i don't know i do i think some of
y'all are just too sensitive
yeah exactly and thank god for that
thank you by the way for defending me
i feel like you know if you're watching
the show and you're perpetually offended
by things i'm saying you may want to
just stop watching like genuinely and
i'm trying my best to learn when i can
and um i did take and learn what i could
from from matt and i listen respectfully
but um to say it's gross and
disappointing which is a comment i'm
reading specifically
uh
is
is just i think you're too sensitive for
the show i really do i'm sorry
i think you need to watch a more safe
podcast
but um
you know i'm always here to learn and
trying to grow but that's just my
opinion because like it is does get
annoying with some of y'all getting
offended all the time about about jokes
that are you know not said with bad
intentions
i see people saying see guys look at
this buys are for ethan thank you for to
the buys
we love our buy communities
do people know we have lgbtq people who
work in the teddy fresh building i don't
care they don't need to know that
they're not tokens
of course we have gay lesbian trans
people that work for us
we have a lot of employees we just
no it's good to bring up but it's like
every chat we see it you know hire
someone
we have people of color we have we have
we work with women we work with lgbtq
people
they're not [ __ ] tokens you know what
i mean you guys literally don't know
what the [ __ ] you don't know anything
about me
you all assume that we're all like cis
men you don't even know that
so i mean
just saying
i'm not gonna [ __ ] like bring out
every person of color that i work with
and be like
this is so and so and they will sh
here's a gay woman and so therefore you
know what i'm saying yeah
it's stupid
that being said a good mix of jews and
muslims here so i should say something
amen brother we got peace going on maybe
yeah really good man bringing peace to
the middle east really you're on the
history podcast
um
you have it so i don't know what to say
you know i i take the i take the
criticism seriously
but sometimes it's it's it's painful to
see people say
really mean things about you like that
you're homophobic or racist or whatever
and when it's like i just i don't see it
i know but i think some people are very
sensitive about these issues which is
fine but i don't think you should
subject yourself to zavic to experience
all the time
on a day on a weekly basis like you're
suffering through this show
i love comments and posts they're like
listen let me start by saying i love
ethan and then it just goes that being
said
i wanna [ __ ] stick ahead i wanna [ __ ]
up his night yeah potentially his
weekend with peace and love pants for
ethan thank you we love our pansexual
audience
we love them the bisexual
we love them folks
clap if you think they should suffer
somebody said
well they clearly want to suffer because
they're watching this podcast everywhere
we don't want them to suffer that's why
they need to just that's why you need to
stop lightly go away yeah
yeah exactly so thank you gays for ethan
thank you
no i love listen i am staunch supporter
of all human rights you know um
trans gay
everything it's it's insane that people
have to justify their existence in this
country
makes it's it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] up
you know so
but okay
if there's things i need to learn to say
better that's fine i'm working on that
too
i got a piece so bad i'm gonna wrap it
up but i'm glad i'm glad we got to talk
about this before the show ended because
i don't want to go and then breed a
thread about everyone being like it's
always the tip there's always the cycle
of people go i super offended and then
people come in and they go you all are
so [ __ ] sensitive and it turns into
this whole civil war on the subreddit
every episode like literally like
clockwork yeah
you know maybe we should just talk about
this openly um
some uh some talk about just getting rid
of uh text posts on the subreddit
yeah i think it might be time for that
it might be time for that it might be
time because um well this person for
example posted a picture of their own
tweet so this one wouldn't
it's a nice little work around like
they're already working right let me
pull up the post that i was reading just
to show you guys i don't know if it
would actually help but somebody
somebody on the subreddit suggested that
recently i saw that and i kind of raised
my eyebrow i'm like you know would the
world really be losing something
if the h3h3 production subreddit i mean
it sucks to have to do that but
i think
like that here they posted a picture of
their own tweet at me
and tagging everybody
come on you talking about power bottoms
like me asking either if she likes it in
the front or back does she ride your
[ __ ] or like you pounding her
respect matt not cool dude
love when you post your own tweets
so i don't know
i guess it will never fix the problem if
people want a [ __ ] they'll find a way
lesbians love h3 ah we love our lesbian
fans
we love
them
we love them
people are saying unsubbed well that's
fine
god bless
all righty guys
so thanks for being here
uh
thank you uh
to
everybody there's been a monday episode
we're going off the rails on wednesday
going way off the rails we got
uh
we might have something
pretty fun for wednesday as well but
that's exciting and i'll talk about what
it is but we are going well off the
rails on wednesday you think we're off
the rails today just wait for wednesday
and friday we have items and then he
says oh that's exciting to talk about
the big fight yep coming up baby yep one
month oh my god i'm excited for it just
be over for you yeah me too
i just want i want the old ab back me
too i feel like dude i missed the old
baby kiss ass before uh the brown knows
her before man work is gonna be a breeze
now i'm gonna be able to just yeah i
missed the whole day b though
i missed the old baby straight from the
goal
baby but you're probably getting
stressed out as you get closer and
closer i just want it to be over with it
just takes up so much time but yeah i'll
be happy to get done with
all right guys we're going to keep the
well anyway we'll be back on wednesday
so if i'll send all your complaints to
the subreddit
and uh we're going to have a whole
we're going to have a whole teaching
moment on wednesday yeah how to we're
going to have like an eight-hour uh
meeting tomorrow actually
and really just go over all of your
comments in detail and really just get
to the bottom of you know how we can
improve yeah we need to be more
respectful to our callers yeah
[Music]
the callers are really the victims here
chested embryos for h3 embryos for h3 we
love our embryos folks we love our
embryos
future h3 fans right there
all right guys i gotta pee so bad we'll
see you on wednesday thanks for watching
everybody bye
you